[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the tim ferriss show
i've been looking forward to this
episode for a while my guest today is
morgan housel
h-o-u-s-e-l you can find him on twitter
at morgan housel he is a partner at the
collaborative fund and a former
columnist at the motley fool in the wall
street journal he serves on the board of
directors at markel corporation he is a
two-time winner of the best in business
award from the society of american
business editors and writers winner of
the new york times sydney award and a
two-time finalist for the gerald loeb
award for distinguished business and
financial journalism his book the
psychology of money has sold more than
one million copies and has been
translated into more than 30
languages morgan welcome to the show
thanks so much for having me tim happy
to be here
so i have
a
just an embarrassment of riches in front
of me in the form of tabs open in this
browser
and one of them
is
a google document that contains my
kindle highlights from
your book and that is the psychology of
money and i have
18 pages of kindle highlights so i
wanted to share that because it's a
whole book it's a whole book
your book was recommended to me several
times and i'm not going to lie the
psychology of money as the title i
thought would be
different in terms of content than it
ended up being so the subtitle timeless
lessons on wealth greed and happiness
which is a great subtitle
i had read
books before i think
attempting to explore certain facets of
psychology
as related to money and the conclusion
usually was spend money on experiences
not possessions and i was like okay
after the 17th round on that i get it i
understand the takeaway
and i was extremely impressed with
how many not just anecdotes but reframes
in the book
caught me off guard or were totally
unknown to me or were hiding in plain
sight as
i'm sure we could explore in multiple
examples so i thought we would begin and
this is actually not where i was
planning on starting but since i'm
blathering on i'll just go there
could you speak to
comparing
warren buffett and jim simons and just
give a little context on
who jim simons is most people will
recognize warren buffett but my brother
and i were speaking about this because i
recommended your book to him which is a
huge reputational risk on my part yeah
he's uh he is for all intents and
purposes a quant phd in statistics also
very literary high bar for books and you
also very much enjoyed your book and
this is one of the
illustrations that stood out to both of
us so if you wouldn't mind just kind of
filling in the color on this and then
we're going to bounce all over the place
tim it starts with a question which
seems like a really straightforward
question of just asking who's the
greatest investor of all time it doesn't
seem like a hard question to answer it
should be an analytic answer it's just
like a number who's had the best
performance but then you can you can
split this different ways so who is the
wealthiest investor of all time that
answer is warren buffett who's the
greatest investor of all time in terms
of like long-term average annual returns
it's jim simons by a mile and like it's
not even close warren buffett's
long-term average annual returns are
about 21 per year jim simons are like 66
per year after his ridiculous fees he's
like in a different universe but warren
buffett is like way wealthier and jim
simons is like a deck of billionaire
himself and this is like a crazy to say
like he's not as rich sounds crazy but
the the like to parse that out the
reason that warren buffett has earned
one-third of the returns but he's like
10 times as wealthy
is because he's biz warren buffett has
been investing for 80 years
and so even though he's not the greatest
investor of all time in annual returns
he has so much endurance in terms of
what he's done that by a mile he's the
wealthiest which to me that gets into a
really interesting point which is
how do you become a great investor and
most people when they hear that what
they think of is like how can i earn the
highest returns what are the highest
returns that i can earn this year and
over the next five years of the next 10
years and that's not bad that can be a
great thing to do but to me if the goal
is to maximize the dollars that you have
just like like what's the way that i can
maximize the amount of dollars i
accumulate over the course of my life
then the answer to that question the
huge majority of time is not
earning the highest returns it's what
are the best returns that you can earn
for the longest period of time which
usually aren't the highest returns that
are out there because maybe you can earn
like maybe you can double your money
this year but can you do that for 50
years in a row like probably not but
could you earn 10 annual returns for 50
years yeah you can totally do that and
generate an enormous uh sum of wealth
all compounding is is returns to the
power of time like time is the exponent
and so that's that's to me what you want
to maximize and that's why warren
buffett is in my mind and it seems like
an easy answer the greatest investor of
all time even though his returns are
probably not even in the top 20 percent
of annualized returns among professional
investors
for people who want to explore jim
simons further i mean he's a
mathematician
by trade so to speak but
fascinating character there's a book
about him i think the title is the man
who solved the market which covers
renaissance technologies and also
tiptoes around a number of other
similar
i would say firms that are very very
secretive for the most part but
fascinating exploration
also completely different uh one would
would probably argue in terms of
approach from warren buffett but
i i'd love to
maybe take a step back and just say
as things are popping to my mind this is
going to be like watching memento sorry
folks but
he
the experience of kovid also showed me
how trained a skill it is
and trainable skill it is to think about
exponential growth curves and
compounding right so for instance most
of the folks who
actually the people who alerted me first
to kovid in january of 2020 and the
people who followed at the closest
were
in my circles all investors right all
active investors and
you know a sort of a good metaphorical
way to explore this would be if you tell
somebody
there's a pond it's a large pond and
every day there is a small growth of
algae that doubles in size and at day 30
the entire pond is covered
at at which point on which day is it
50 covered right and the day is
number 29 right but it's sort of
counterintuitive to think about
and
just to connect that to what we're
talking about this is the other thing
that that i suppose should have been
obvious
but it was kind of hiding in plain sight
and that is the percentage of warren
buffett's wealth
his total let's just call it net worth
that he has
accrued since what age 50 age 65 how
does it work out roughly i know i'm
asking you to kind of memorize your book
which is not fair but do you recall
often yeah the math behind it is 99 of
his wealth was accumulated after his
50th birthday and 97 came after his 65th
birthday which is a really obvious thing
if you think about how compounding works
like it's always
in the extreme later
end of year is that it that the numbers
just start getting ridiculous
compounding is just like you know it
starts slow and then it's boring and for
10 years it's boring for 20 years it
starts to get pretty cool and then 30
years you're like wow and then 40 50
years it's like holy like it just
explodes into something incredible
there's a friend of mine named michael
batnick who once explained
compound growth and i think the the most
easy way to comprehend which is if i ask
you what is eight plus eight plus eight
plus eight you you can figure that out
in your head in three seconds like
anyone can do that that's no problem but
if i say what is eight times eight times
eight times eight times eight like your
head's gonna explode trying to think
about it it's like all compounding is
never intuitive and that's why if we
look at someone like buffett we in the
financial industry have spent so much
time trying to answer the question how
has he done it and we go into all this
detail about how he thinks about moats
and business models and market cycles
and valuations which are all important
topics but we know that the literally 99
of the answer to the question how has he
accumulated this much wealth is just
that he's been a good investor for 80
years it's just the time and if buffett
had retired at age 60 like a normal
person might you no one would have ever
heard of him
he would have been like one of hundreds
of people who retired with a couple
hundred million bucks and like moved to
florida to play golf he never would have
been a household name he would have been
a great investor of course but there's a
lot of great investors out there the
only reason he became a household name
is just his endurance and his longevity
that's it and that's why if you go back
to like even the late 1990s not that
long ago warren buffett was known within
circles like within investing circles
people knew who he was but he didn't
become a household name until the early
and mid 2000s which is that's when the
compounding took his net worth to become
worth 20 billion 50 billion 100 billion
where he is right now it's just the
amount of time he's been doing it for
so
let's take a closer look at warren
buffett and
charlie munger i know you are
certainly a fan of charlie munger
probably warren buffett as well what do
people get wrong about the two of them
i i would just love to know what you
think people
misinterpret
or over interpret
aside from the longevity piece right
just the
tally of years
involved with compounding and
let's let's just start with that broad
question
i think one of the things that's easy to
minimize is that buffett is a very good
communicator he's a very good writer
he's a very good speaker that's a big
part of why he became a household name
when he writes his annual letters when
he goes on cnbc it's it's easy to
understand anyone can understand it and
that has created the impression that
what he does is really simple
and i think it's led a lot of people to
be like oh i can go out and pick a good
business and read a balance sheet and i
can do all this too because it sounds so
easy when warren does it and it's not
it's there's so much nuance and i think
gut feelings that have just accumulated
over 80 years of doing this
that has made particularly in the early
and mid 2000s value investing was very
popular it's it's not in this era but in
the last era it was and there were a lot
of people
a lot of
fun managers a lot of investors who
would read a couple warren buffett
annual letters and be like i could do
this i could totally do this and they go
out and try to do it and there's a
reason why quoting warren buffett is
easier than being the next warren
buffett like it sounds so simple when
you're like oh be greedy when others are
fearful it's so simple and then you go
out and try to do it and october 2008
rolls around and you're like ah this is
actually way harder than i thought so i
think it's it's it's very easy to
oversimplify what he's done and that's
why there are hundreds of books titled
you know some version of how to invest
like warren buffett and they all it's
all so overly simplified when actually
what they do is is really complex and
even if it's not complex they're just at
us they being berkshire and and
buffett and mugger are at a size now
where they can do things that other
people can't you know whether it's you
know just picking up the phone and
calling the ceo of goldman sachs to get
a special preferred stock investment
that kind of stuff there's things that
other people can't do um the other thing
that's
i think easy to overlook is that you
know berkshire is now a six or seven
hundred billion dollar company something
like that so the odds that they are
going to achieve market beating returns
in any significant way i think round to
zero and it's it's a casualty of its own
success that when berkshire was a tiny
company in the 70s and 80s they could
they could go out and buy small cap
companies and do things that now you
know berkshire's largest investment now
is apple and i think there's two reasons
for that one is because it's a great
company and it's of course it's a great
company two is that the number of
publicly traded companies that can
actually move the needle in berkshire's
portfolio is probably like 10. there's
probably like 10 companies that are
actually investable that you can
actually he could actually look at and
say we can put some put some money to
work there and apples just happens to be
one of them so i think the odds that
berkshire will outperform over the long
term are very slim and if it does
outperform it's going to be minuscule
that's okay there's nothing wrong with
that but i think a lot of people have
been disappointed because buffett became
famous in the mid 2000s and a lot of
people started buying berkshire stock
and becoming part of that cult and the
stock since then has not done very well
and i think that's almost inevitable at
the size that it is that it's just it's
not going to outperform anymore
that's true with a lot of things right i
can't remember where i first heard this
expression i want to say it's somehow
associated with
collaborative fund actually but i don't
know where it began which is the size is
the strategy
in other words if you're if you're a
fund of funds and you're picking fund
managers
part of the calculus is going to be
perhaps finding a sweet spot where
somebody's not in asset accumulation
mode just to earn their management fee
they're not going to be able to buy that
amazing 50 million dollar mansion in
miami on the management fees just yet
right so they're still out there to beat
the world
so the size of the fund or the size of
the company or the size of the fill in
the blank kind of becomes one of the
main parameters for
picking
you see that actually in a lot of fields
there's this thing in evolutionary
biology called cope's rule
it's it's not a law because it's not
very universal but cope's rule basically
says that organisms get bigger over time
so you know if you look at the evolution
of humans we used to be half of our
height that we were as we evolved over
the years you get bigger and you went
from like little worms that turned into
boa constrictors like most species get
bigger over time so then the question is
why aren't all species just enormous if
getting big is better because you are a
better hunter you can hunt more prey why
aren't we all huge and the answer is
because like there's huge downsides to
being big you can't hide from from other
prey you need an enormous amount of food
to keep yourself going there's always a
sweet spot in evolution of like big
helps but only to a certain point and we
see this like
one of the areas that this really became
clear
that size is a it size helps you but it
also has huge downsides were banks in
the early and mid 2000s where the
economies to scale to banking are
enormous like when you're a big bank you
have a lower cost of capital you can
raise money you have regulatory capital
you own the politicians etc like you
want to be a big bank that's the sweet
spot but then there's this really
interesting thing like we all know what
happened to the banks in the mid 2000s
but one of the most fascinating stories
that i remember is
citigroup in the mid-2000s had this
product on its balance sheet i forget
what it was called it was like a cdo
putback basically what it meant in
layman's terms was
cdo had all of these collateralized debt
obligations these junk bonds and there
was like a little footnote in them that
hey if the value of these bonds declines
if these investments go sour to these
clients we're selling them to we
citigroup will buy them back at par at
full price
and when the mortgage market imploded
citigroup was obligated to repurchase
like tens of billions of dollars in
these junk bonds and that was a big part
of what sent them over the edge and
nearly bankrupt the company the
interesting thing about this is that
robert rubin who was a former treasury
secretary and a partner at goldman sachs
like one of the most
like astute sophisticated experienced
financial minds in the world was on the
citigroup board of directors at the time
and he afterwards said that he had never
even heard the name of this product he
had never even heard of it this product
that could nearly bankrupt the entire
company had they had the ability to
almost bank up the company the chairman
or the guy who sat on the board had
never even heard of it before so that to
me like you can criticize robert rubin
for that but that to me just showed that
citigroup was just too big to manage
there's too much going on for any sane
person to understand what was going on i
i actually empathize with a lot of those
too big to fail bankers and look you
know should they have lost all their
wealth of of course but i there's no way
that anyone at citigroup or jp morgan or
wells fargo or any of those banks can
honestly say that they know what's going
on inside of them they're just too damn
big to understand it
part of what i enjoy about
your
mind and commentary is that it spans the
spans from the macro to the intensely
personal so i'm gonna come back to
buffett monger but i'm going to take a
detour for a moment lest people think
we're going to get too into the weeds on
on banks for the next hour which we we
might get into a bit more of it but i
want to go to a piece that you wrote
some time ago
and this is financial advice for my new
son
you wrote this
october 13th republished it october 13th
2015 so that's let's just call it
six years ago a bit over six years ago
and your son had been born the week
before and you listed out
a number of different
i wouldn't say rules but
bits of financial advice and one one
that stuck out to me that i particularly
enjoyed i'm just going to read it here
because it's it's it's one of those
things again that is
obvious once you've heard it obvious in
retrospect but the framing
is very
helpful and i hadn't read it presented
in just this way so number one you might
think you want an expensive car a fancy
watch in a huge house but i'm telling
you you don't what you want is respect
and admiration from other people and you
think having expensive stuff will bring
it it almost never does especially from
the people you want to respect and
admire you
here's the paragraph that stuck out to
me when you see someone driving a nice
car you probably don't think wow that
person is cool instead you think wow if
i had that car people would think i'm
cool do you see the irony no one cares
about the guy in the car have fun buy
some nice stuff but realize that what
people are really after is respect and
humility will ultimately gain you more
of it than vanity now the the last
sentence
has some counter examples maybe yes but
the
point that we rarely look at the person
in the cool car and say wow that person
must be cool rather we apply it to
ourselves is i think a very profound
observation
what would you add to this list and
people can certainly find this we'll
link to in the show notes people can
find it easily but
is there anything you would add to this
list now six years later or that you
would
change in any material way
well first let me let me give some
insight into that man-in-the-car paradox
as i call it when i was in college i was
a valet at a high-end hotel in los
angeles so i was in my early 20s and
there were people coming in and ferraris
and lamborghinis and rolls-royces like
the whole the whole thing
and it dawned on me one day that when
those cars pulled in that i had really
admired i'm a car guy i'd love that
never once did i look at the driver and
say that guy's cool what i did is i
imagined myself as a driver and i
thought people would think i'm cool and
this was like i was in my early 20s but
i'm just thinking like this that was my
first kind of light bulb into how wealth
works that everyone thinks that they
want to be the driver but no one
actually is paying attention to the
driver they're imagining themselves
people think about themselves way more
than they think about other people and
but we all think that everyone's looking
at us i think that's like a universal
thing everyone thinks like oh this
person is looking at me they're
impressed with me by and large they're
not they're thinking about themselves
and how other people might want to be
impressed with them
so that was some some insight into that
view what i would add today now that my
son is six and we have a two-year-old
daughter as well and i think i knew this
before becoming a parent but until
you're a parent it's just hard to fathom
how powerful it is it's just you have no
clue
who your kids are gonna grow up to be
and i saw this especially when my
daughter was born and now that my
daughter is two they are so different
from one another my son and daughter
completely different despite growing up
with the same parents in the same house
with the same means everything they
could not be more night and day now of
course they're four years apart and
they're different genders of course but
they it's the personality differences
are so stark and that just makes me
think like whenever you want to
picture or imagine who your kids
might be someday it's like you have no
clue what they're going to grow up to be
i think that it's intuitive to think
that my kids will grow up similar to my
wife and i because i'm going to instill
in them the values that my wife and i
value
but they're like they're so starkly
different from one another and i'm so
different from my brother and sister we
went so completely different ways in
life that it's it's so hard to give your
kids advice when they're young when you
have no clue where they're going to end
up so people have asked me this question
similar to you know on on going off of
that article
what would i teach them now or or or how
am i teaching my my son about money now
that he's old enough to start to get the
basics of it and the truth is i'm really
not because i don't know maybe when he's
a young adult he wants to be a partner
at goldman sachs maybe he wants to work
for green peace like who knows what he's
going to be and therefore i can't give
him or anyone universal financial advice
and say this is what you should do this
is what you should value this is where
you should go because we're all so
incredibly different in our goals and
our talents and our aspirations
are there not traits or
characteristics that you could cultivate
that would be somewhat
agnostic
in the sense that
i know this is a study that's come under
some scrutiny if you want to even call
it a study but the marshmallow test
right so are there not
ways of not necessarily
improving their financial
iq or investment iq but cultivating
certain characteristics
that that may be
helpful right and i'm looking at a piece
by jason zweig am i pronouncing that
correctly yeah uh fantastic writer this
is a this is a i say journalist and this
is a great piece discussing your book do
you know the difference between being
rich and being wealthy and one of the
lines that i like in this is investing
isn't an iq test it's a test of
character
so could you speak to that
i think if there is a universal trait of
money that's true for
like not not a hundred percent of people
but let's say 90 of people is that what
people really want in life is
independence and autonomy i think no
matter where you're from what you do
what your aspirations are that's a
common denominator that people just want
to wake up every morning and do what
they want to do on their own terms and
whether they're able to do that whether
they can actually do that today or
that's a goal i think that's a that's a
universal trait among people it's just
independence and autonomy and so to the
extent that we can use money to gain
that to gain independence and autonomy
that is i think as close as it comes to
a universal want and thing that we can
use money for the interesting thing to
me is that
among
huge numbers of people educated people
financial professionals the purpose of
money is to buy stuff it's to accumulate
more stuff bigger house nicer car
whatever it might be which is great i
love all that stuff too
but to me the the most powerful thing
that money can do and the most universal
benefit that it can bring us
is systematically overlooked like using
it for independence and autonomy is so
overlooked and that that to me has
always been kind of a sad thing that we
are so accustomed and attuned to just
wanting to use our money whatever money
that we have whatever savings that we
have to go out and buy more stuff when
we could be using it for freedom on
autonomy and then when you come to a
period like in
uh march and april of 2020 or october
2008 when millions of people lose their
jobs and you see during those periods
like the early day of kovitz how many
people are just on the razor's edge of
insolvency and it does not take them
much you know one or two weeks of
unemployment to be in a really bad
financial spot whether that's for an
individual or a small business it does
not take that much to be thrown over the
edge and you realize how dependent so
many people are on
their jobs their salaries their their
customers in a short period of time and
there's just not a lot of room for error
throughout most of the world and i think
for the huge majority of people not
everyone but for the majority of people
there could be a lot more and the reason
that they don't want to have more
savings is because to them the knee-jerk
reaction is why would i just keep my
money in the bank or even invest it like
the purpose of money is to go out and
buy more stuff to enjoy my life i get
that i understand it but it's usually
once every five or ten years that people
realize how important independence and
autonomy is and having that wealth that
you have not spent having the money that
you haven't spent that was just laying
around doing nothing becomes the most
valuable thing in the world when it lets
you gain control of your time and just
wake up every morning and say i can do
whatever the hell i want today i think
that's as close as it gets to him to
like a universal financial law all right
we may come back to the kids but i'm
gonna leave the kids alone i'm gonna go
to your parents instead what did your
parents do professionally the short
backstory well to answer the question my
dad was an er doctor my mom was an er
nurse
they're both retired now but they got to
it in a really interesting way my
parents met on a hippie comm unit in the
1970s in tennessee and my dad started
his undergraduate college when he was 30
and had three kids and he became a
doctor when he was like 43 or something
like that and had three teenagers so he
had kids after
after he began his undergrad in his 30s
well i'm the youngest of three and i
think he started undergraduate like the
month after i was born wow um that's
when he started undergrad and then he
became a doctor when i was 12 or
something like that and my brother would
have been 18 at that point so he got a
very late start which is a very like
when he started everyone i think from
his parents to the professors like what
are you trying to do you're going to
become a doc like what you're out of
your mind but but he didn't he ground
through it and did it and what's
interesting about that financial story
is that we grew up me we'd be my whole
family when i was a young kid very very
poor my parents were students we were
living off of grants and like low-income
housing like we were poor we had a great
childhood but we were very poor and then
my dad became a doctor when we were in
our early teenage years and then had a
comfortable upper-middle-class life from
there but the frugality that was forced
upon my parents when they were poor
stuck around so my parents had a very
high savings rate we lived we lived a
great life we had a nice house drove
fined cars we went on some cool
vacations it was not it was not living
poor at all but my parents had a very
high savings rate and we lived they
lived well below their means because
that's how they it was forced upon them
for decades of living like that and then
when this was like now if we fast
forward to the last 10 years my dad
after working in the er for 20 or 25
years which is probably one of the most
stressful
fields of medicine you can go into
because people are literally literally
dying in your arms every day it's very
it's a very stressful profession so
after 20 years he just kind of had
enough and since he had a high savings
rate he could as soon as he got to the
day where he decided he had enough he
just left he quit and he could do it on
his own terms when he wanted to and he
had all these colleagues who for years
had been living a much better life than
him bigger houses nicer cars sending
their kids to better schools all that
and they wanted to quit and they
couldn't they were just as burned out
but they needed to put in another 10
years of doing it and i think watching
that watching my dad just getting to a
point where he said i don't want to do
this anymore so i'm going to leave
tomorrow it was like ah that clicked
with me like that's why you were so
cheap growing up which i which i looked
down upon you for when i was young
saying why don't we spend more money but
now i get it you have he has pure
independence and autonomy and the
happiness that he and my mom got from
that i think exceeds the happiness that
he would have gotten from driving a
porsche or living in a bigger house a
hundredfold literally a hundredfold he's
been so happy over the last decade just
doing what he wants to do particularly
retiring as he slows down as his body
and mind slow down as he aged to be able
to do what he wants i i literally think
it's a hundred times happier than he
would have been if he lived a better
material life when he was young so that
was a really profound takeaway from me
watching that what type of hippie
commune did they meet on in tennessee
it's called the farm it's still in
existence it's a tiny tiny fraction of
what it used to be but back in the 1970s
it's a hippie communion called called
the farm and it was huge it was like
thousands of people and it was it was
truly was a communi you were not allowed
to have your own financial assets you
couldn't have your own bank when you
joined the farm when you got there you
had to forfeit all of your possessions
all of your money all of your assets had
to be donated to the farm and everyone
worked
together my pe they were farmers my dad
like my dad flew a crop dusting plane he
was a pilot before he moved to the farm
and everyone worked together now of
course the punch line here is it failed
it it totally it fell apart eventually
as you would imagine but my parents i
was talking to i was talking about it
just last week they have nothing but
incredible memories from it they were in
their early and mid-20s when they were
doing it and they met
like their best friends still to this
day are from there they have nothing but
great experiences from it even if the
whole thing fell apart that was like the
that was like the 70s of course was like
peak baby boomer
you know this is like that it was a
really cool thing to do to live on this
hippie copying back in the 1970s so your
dad after
let's call 20 25 years of
working as an er doc decides to
walk just call it quits retire he's able
to do that
as you pointed out for a number of
reasons
freedom and autonomy
i have
found and observed
not perhaps
surprisingly carries with it a lot of
responsibility and it seems that
sometimes people who are frugal for a
very very long time
then have extreme difficulty spending
money
on themselves
to sort of improve their quality of life
or experience of life
post let's just say retirement in this
case
how have have your parents how or how
has your dad used this freedom and
autonomy right because it's a lot of
hours in the day how is that panned out
at first i'd say they're they're the
happiest that i've ever seen them now in
the last couple years they bought a
piece of land on the coast in northern
california and they are just like
small-time farmers they're vegetarians
they've been vegetarians for 45 years
and they grow like two-thirds of the
food that they eat so they spend all of
their day in their little personal farm
doing it and they love it they don't
need to do that but they absolutely love
it they have a tractor and they got all
these cool tools they'd absolutely love
doing it and it's all in their own terms
they and they they take naps every day
they go for bike rides along the coast
like they have a lot of fun doing it
that's amazing so they've come full
circle in a sense from the farm to the
farm it sounds like including you know
during the doctor's years my dad looked
like a a professional and now he's back
to full hippie long gray ponytail it all
it all goes full circle it all comes
back
all right so we might dig further into
your dad's career decision to go to
undergrad at let's let's say 30 and then
pursue medicine but i want to talk about
your trajectory since
you'll have
presumably more
detail and and insight there
you also and i should give credit where
credit is due for some of this due
diligence i listened to shane parish's
interview with you on the knowledge
project i believe it is yep so that's
where i'm pulling this from so your
illustrious career began as a greeter at
denny's that did not pan out was not
your vocation it turned out so i was
crushed but yes that's correct
so denny's out
enter stage left valet as i understand
it and that continued for eight or nine
years something like that yeah something
along those lines i did it all
throughout college before and before and
after and your major was econ that's
right okay major's econ then you try
investment banking
and
the
if you don't come into work on saturday
don't bother coming in on sunday haha
wink wink not really joking sort of
hyper competitive cutthroat environment
was not for you
right you moved to
private equity which you did enjoy yes
they sort of deep dive
study of companies buying and presumably
at some point selling entire companies
things like this
but that was
roughly 2007 from getting the timing
right or i guess it came to its end in
2007 where
the parting conversation was you're not
fired but you can't work here anymore
that's that's that's a verbatim
statement i remember sitting there
thinking i'm i'm pretty sure you just
fired me but thank you for being polite
about it so i'm very curious to know i
had to i have to ask like was that a
very clever way of trying to circumvent
severance or was it just a weird way of
firing you and then giving you severance
how did that pan out most private equity
firms in the summer of 2007 knew they
were in in deep [ __ ] it was a really
tough time for people when you're
borrowing a ton of money to lever these
low-quality businesses up like that was
a tough time they saw the writing on the
wall and i think they were just trying
to scale back as quickly as i could the
idea was so i was a summer interim at
the time and the idea was i was going to
stick around full-time after college and
become a full-time employee
which would have been that fall and so
that was the plan was kind of all
sketched out like here's what i'm going
to do i'm going to stick around and then
just before
i was going to start full time is when
they said hey like there's there's not
going to be there's not going to be a
spot here for you so i'm sure their
wording was not was not intentional but
that that wording of you're not fired
but you can't work here anymore
was was a funny i remember i remember
walking out and being like so wait so do
i come back tomorrow i don't know
yeah very confusing delivery i don't
know is this
the tao teiching or like what are we
doing here people so my question to you
then after that as if my memory is
serving me which i hope it does because
i listened to this episode with shane a
few hours ago
you ended up having a conversation with
a friend who i believe was writing at
motley fool at the time
and asked if you'd be interested in
sort of kicking the tires and writing
for a bit you did not have a background
as a writer
per se although i imagine you did some
writing we're going to come back to the
high school education in quotation marks
which we can explore
but
you ended up trying that thinking it was
going to be a short experiment and then
you stuck with it and now you've written
i would have to imagine at this point
what 4 000 plus articles or 3 000 plus
articles lots yeah and my question for
you is
i banking
private equity
that that is the the meandering not
meandering but like the kind of winding
path of of one who might aspire to be
one of the masters of the universe right
yeah and
then you choose writing and you stick
with writing which
has a very different financial payoff
profile
than the finance track yep
why were you comfortable doing that or
how did you make that decision
i would say i was comfortable i wouldn't
even say it was a decision it really was
in the summer of 2007 so i graduated in
2008 so as everything fell apart i
thought i wanted to be an investment
banker and then i realized i don't it's
the culture of it was not for me and
then i thought great so i'll go into
private equity and then all those
positions just disintegrated before my
eyes i just needed something to do i
just needed a job and
like like you said i had a friend who's
a writer at the motley fool who said
morgan you should apply you're like
you're interested in investing just
apply and i thought hey they're not
going to hire me and even if they do
maybe i'll do it for six months before i
find another private equity job so it
was really just out of desperation that
i became a writer that's the right word
for it it was it was not a plan i didn't
even enjoy it i wasn't excited about it
it was just like how i need a paycheck i
would say the first year of that two was
not very much fun because i really had
no writing background at all i was an
econ major in college where it's heavily
math-based so you know there's not much
writing it's like as long as you can
write your name at the top of the test
that's all that's required of you and so
i had no writing background
and then so the first year was really
hard because i had no idea what i was
doing both on the investing front like i
had no idea what i was talking about and
on the writing front i just didn't know
how to write a good paragraph and it was
tough particularly as anyone in online
writing or even social media knows if
you say something wrong online people
will tell you about it in no uncertain
terms so i was just you know as part of
my job i was just getting torn to shreds
day after day it just wasn't any fun but
after i would say a year or maybe two
years i felt like i started to get a
little i started get the hang of it and
i started to be like oh how can i okay i
i understand investing better and i feel
like oh i can start telling a little bit
of a story that people might enjoy
and rather than just being a capital j
journalist and just like throwing
numbers on the page and hitting publish
maybe i can tell a story that will
resonate with people and if i twist the
phrases this way and if i try to be
funny in this way and tell a tale in
this way then i can stick out in this
financial media world that is so
competitive and there's so many other
people who are writing about the same
stocks that i do that if i can tell a
story it's more fun and it catches
people's attention and even after that
so now we're in like 2009 2010 i would
say it wasn't until probably 2014 or 15
that i felt like i really started
hitting a stride of like oh i can kind
of figure out what i'm doing here and i
i kind of feel like i've cracked the
formula of what works in a finance
article
and so it was really you know five to
seven years of just kind of hacking my
way through trying to put the pieces
together to figure it out before i
really started a enjoying it and felt
like i had some aptitude of doing a good
job at it and in the vein of sort of
career crafting whether by
of your own volition or via desperation
or chance i suppose we're all a
combination of probably those things on
some level you've written for a number
of different outlets how did you end up
and i'd like to know both of these a
partner a collaborative fund which is a
venture capital firm
and how did you end up on the board of
directors of markel corporation and you
should also probably explain
what markel corporation is and what they
do this is not a small company
so i would love to know the answers to
both of those okay let's start with
collaborative fun at the time i was at
the motley fool at the time being about
let's go back to 2015. i was at the
motley fool and my plan was i was going
to stay at the motley fool for life
including my wife and i bought a house
half a mile from my full headquarters in
virginia the plan was we're going to
stay there forever
one day a guy named craig shapiro
emailed me and said hey i'm craig i run
this tiny venture capital firm called
called collaborative fun i read your
stuff let's grab lunch
and normally if if someone sent me that
email i would just delete i wouldn't
even respond to it i would literally
just delete it that's a that's a
personality flaw of mine but that's how
i respond to those kind of things but i
happened i was in new york that day
where craig is from and someone had just
canceled a meeting so i had some free
time so i get this email from a guy in
new york who says hey let's meet and i
said great i'm i'm two blocks away let's
meet right now so i met craig shapiro
and he just turned out to be he's
he's one of those people and i'm really
being sincere when i say this i'm not
just blowing smoke because he's my boss
he was one of those people who right
away i was like ah this guy like he and
i see eye to eye on how the world works
like is it like we we we disagree here
and there but in the broad strokes of
how to live a good life and how
investing works and where the economy is
going craig and i really see eye to eye
on the big picture stuff and that was
clear right away so it was probably
about a year after that
that he said hey you should join
collaborative fun and just keep writing
about the things that you do and i said
craig like thanks but no like i'm really
happy at the motley fool i'm gonna stay
here forever not interested in it and he
just kind of kept chipping away and it
took me a long time to figure out that
like oh no like i i really see the
vision of what he's trying to build and
i like it i like the brand i like him
personally he's a great guy and i also
knew that he was gonna give me complete
autonomy to write about whatever i
wanted whenever i wanted and just make
the blog my own little canvas that i
could paint on that was really important
to me and it was clear that he was going
to let me do that so then i joined
collaborative fund which is a venture
capital firm private equity firm kind of
invest in lots of different asset
classes now
and my whole job is to write and speak
and not even write about venture capital
or not even to write about our portfolio
just write about
things that i see where the world's
going things that i think are important
for investing investing history and
investing behavior the idea for it the
idea for having a writer like that at a
venture capital firm by and large is
look if you are a venture capitalist
money is fungible so if your only
asset as a firm is we can write a check
well that you you do not stand apart at
all a lot of people can write a check
you stand apart in the private investing
world by having values and a view of the
world that is differentiated in in some
way and those values that view do not
matter at all unless people know about
them so you need to be kind of going out
there showing the world how you think
what you think who you are waving your
arms so that's that's the purpose of
hiring someone like me to be a writer
you can call it marketing if you want
although nothing i write about is saying
here's why we're great and here's why we
should do this i do that intentionally
because i don't want it to sound like
marketing even if it is i i like no one
wakes up every morning and says i want
to read a marketing article they just
want to read something that's
interesting and
and thought stimulating that they can
share with their friends so that's what
i do and that's what i've done for the
last six years is just writing about all
the different things that i think are
interesting
and uh trying to do a bunch of reading
and thinking and talking to friends
trying to learn something and then
sharing sharing it with the world that's
how i got started at club yeah kudos to
craig we're going to come back to
markelle in a moment but
he was he was very
prescient in that uh
in that chess move of his
with the persistent recruiting
to get you on board and you we've seen i
mean certainly
the
this this word bothers me but i can't
think of a better term because it's it's
multimedia but the sort of content
aspect of
differentiation
by venture firms we've seen first-round
capital do a pretty good job of this i
think and there are others now but the
the timeline that you're laying out
would have placed craig and
collaborative on very
early right paddling for the right wave
early in that respect
how did you think about giving up
the masthead so to speak i mean
presumably the offer was also a good
offer right the the actual sort of
compensation and deal as it were we
don't need to get into the specifics of
that
but i'm asking in part because i've
thought about
paying journalists
and i spoke with actually nick thompson
about this
when i had him on the podcast
very very
super competitive
her
per word rates to do long-form pieces on
my blog right but the problem with the
tim ferriss blog is that sim versus blog
does not carry the same cachet perhaps
as you know the newspaper of record
self-described or
other outlets right so how did you think
about the
if any kind of long-term career
consequences of of
swapping the masthead in that way
it worried me at the time because i was
i'd been at the motley fool for 10 years
and i felt like i built up an audience
there
and i had no idea if any of them would
would travel with me and if i went
somewhere else would do like did i have
to start at square one and build myself
up from zero that was terrifying or was
it or was that audience gonna be
somewhat portable and i think the answer
is like somewhere in the middle but i
think it felt okay to me because i think
this is obvious now i mean but it wasn't
obvious you know five or ten years ago
that
people don't necessarily read the new
york times they read by and large
certain writers at the new york times i
don't read the atlantic i read derek
thompson i don't read the wall street
journal i read jason's wag it's all
about those people now there's some
there's some nuance to that like you
know there's some places like the
economists that have no bylines it's
just like you're reading one voice but i
think by and large people want to read
certain writers they want to make it
personal one example of this is most
corporate twitter accounts do not do
very well they don't get any engagement
they don't do very well but personal
twitter accounts for people like
yourself can do very well because people
don't want to interact with a company
they want to interact with a person and
i think so leaving the masthead so to
speak that actually didn't bother me
that much
because i i didn't want to be a wall
street journal writer or even a motley
fool writer i wanted to be
morgan hassell i just wanted to be i
wanted to build the name that's very
selfish but i think it's true i think it
i think it's true for a lot of people
the url of your blog is tim.blog like
it's your name right there i think
making branding that after yourself and
being kind of
explicit about that is the right way to
go in content these days because people
want to interact with a person so that
that didn't bother me
it's good if you're in it for the ultra
long haul
i.e to the end of your life if you're
building a media brand to sell it's
problematic to have it named after you
or
it can be complicating certainly but
that's not my plan so it's not not a
concern for me so team dot blog it is
for the time being
markell how did markel happen well first
i'm sure there's listeners who don't
know what markel is the easiest way to
describe markel is a mini berkshire
hathaway in the sense that it is an
insurance company that uses the profits
from the insurance company to buy whole
businesses industrial businesses that it
plans on holding forever which is
exactly what the berkshire hathaway
model was and that's really what markell
was as well markell started in the 1930s
as an insurance company and it was that
for many years now every insurance
company in the world
does investments because you use the
proceeds from your insurance premiums to
invest most insurance companies will
just do that in bonds maybe some index
funds pretty boring and it's not until
you have a company like berkshire that's
like hey we got all this money laying
around let's go buy some amazing
businesses that's how berkshire hathaway
and warren buffett became what they are
and markell started doing that really
around the 1990s when they realized that
you could become a great business and a
great incredible company if you are not
just a good insurer that's really
important but if you can be a good
insurer and a great investor with those
insurance proceeds at the same time you
can be an incredible company so so now
if we fast forward today markel is
a 17 billion dollar company with 20 000
employees they own
you know about a dozen industrial
businesses of various sizes and it's a
really cool company it's a company that
i've admired for a very long period of
time i'll tell you a little quirky story
here when you join the motley fool as an
employee they give you a small sum of
money to invest in any stock that you
want they want to want every employee to
be an investor when i became an employee
in 2007 i got my little allocation and i
invested every penny in markel at the
time true story because i really admired
what they were doing the guy who who is
co-ceo runs a place tom gainer i really
think is one of the great investors of
our time
and so i've admired it for a long time
and then about a year ago
i got a call from the company and this
asked if i would be interested in
joining the board of directors and i
said yeah
yes
i admire them so much of course so what
the hell did they say i'm just so
curious like how does that happen
because i looked at the website i was
like well let me see if there are like
75 people on the board of directors uh
there are not 75 people it's it's it's
reasonably small so please fill in the
gaps here no i really wish the story was
more interesting but that's really it
they called me up i had never spoken
with them before at all no communication
and they said would you like to join the
board once that phone call ended began a
year of meeting everyone discussing
everything flying out to meet them them
flying to seattle to meet me like a long
process as you would expect any big
corporation would have i think very
similar to craig
tom gainer who's the co-ceo and i see
the world through a very similar lens of
just like what what does an investing
company or an investor need for
long-term success having just those big
macro values aligned i think was really
important so it was it was an obvious
answer for me and then getting to know
the rest of the board over the last
12 months has been really interesting
it's a very diverse board um diverse in
terms of gender race and also just
background so it's like it's a really
diverse set of views and set of opinions
within the boardroom and then i joined
the boardroom just about six weeks ago
so i'm still oh it's very new fairly new
at this yeah so i have to imagine that
there are
thousands of people who would claim to
have similar
macro views or world views to people who
are on the board of markel nonetheless
they're not getting the invitation to
join
the board so how did they explain
what they hope you two contribute
one thing that's that's interesting i i
do think this there is some
misconception about what a board member
does and the important thing is
explaining what a board member does not
do which has run the company and a board
member's job is not to micromanage the
company or it's not even to set like the
the grand strategy for the company it's
really to be an overseer of the company
and to kind of be the boss of the
executive team to hire the ceo fire the
ceo and pay the ceo that's that's the
biggest job of the board those are huge
responsibilities they're huge
responsibilities there's a great quote
from a guy named lawrence cunningham who
says that
being on the board of a large company is
corporate america's highest honor and
heaviest burden and it's it's it's
easier to focus on the first part and
ignore the latter part but yeah it's
it's right those are huge burdens and
again i'm speaking with six weeks of
experience here i'm not going to pretend
like i have lots of war stories to share
with you about this because i don't but
i think seeing eye to eye on the big
picture of where the company is going
and what it needs to do it right and
just having experience for myself as an
investor as someone who thinks about
risk and have done that for my entire
career is important what i do not have
is experience running an insurance
company experience running a company
with 19 000 employees those are things
that i do not have but i think i do
bring to the table both a generational
diversity of like if you look at
the boards of all public companies i
mean you're looking at an average age of
something like in the mid 70s something
like that it tends to be an older group
that came of age during a similar time
and i think sees the world through a
similar lens that is not exactly you
know the clearest lens of where of where
the world is going next so i think
having a generational diversity has has
been important that was explained to me
and i think just having a view about
risk and about what matters in investing
as well
and that's really it it's been an
interesting experience for me it was not
a job that i
thought was gonna coming my way but it's
a it's a cool job to have that i know
has a very heavy burden it's it's cool
to put it on your resume and talk to
your friends about it but i think like a
lot of things there's a great quote from
jeff immelt who's a former ceo of
general electric who says every job
looks easy when you're not the one doing
it i think that's a great quote that
applies to a lot of things and i think
that's true for sitting on a board as
well it seems like a great position and
a fun kind of cushy position in many
ways it is but you realize even from day
one my first meeting the burden that is
on you for making the right decisions
and if things go wrong realizing the
spotlight's gonna be on you and you
deserve that well congratulations i have
to say i mean there's there's
responsibility and there's the potential
burden of making a poor decision or
being blamed for a poor decision but i
it strikes me as nothing but upside
potential for you i mean it's it seems
like a pretty fantastic
experiment so congratulations thanks
like i said i was appointed six weeks
ago i've been to one meeting but even in
that one meeting i would say tim it's
obvious
from the get-go
the burden the responsibility that you
have and there is a little bit i think
this would be true for anyone in this
position a little bit like of an oh [ __ ]
moment of like oh i i realize the
decisions that need to be
that need to be made there's a good
friend of mine named brent bishor who
says every successful business is a
loosely functioning disaster every
single successful business in the world
that's as good as you can get that's the
highest peak is a loosely functioning
disaster every business is just a mix of
personalities and emotions and imperfect
information and you're just trying to
hold the thing together and do the best
that you can and you really see that
when you're on the inside of any company
that exists in the world so that's
that's always apparent for me just as an
outside investor looking at any company
or on the inside as well like all
businesses are tough and challenging and
you need to make tough decisions and
imperfect decisions to get ahead
when you say risk viewing risk in a
similar or the same way
how do you view risk or if you were to
explain it to a class
with respect to how you view risk in
investing let's say
how would you how would you define that
or begin to explore it or misconceptions
thereof
let me start with a short story that i
was talking with a friend of mine last
week derek thompson of the atlantic he
and i did did a podcast together and he
asked me if i thought inflation would be
transitory which is a very common
question that a lot of people are
talking about right now and i said well
what does transitory mean by transitory
do you mean it's gonna be gone in a week
do you mean it's gonna stick around for
10 years all these like little weasel
words that don't have any agreed upon
definition you can really get into a lot
of trouble there because i think
inflation is transitory but by that i
mean it's probably not going to stick
around for five years if your definition
of transitory means it's gonna be gone
next week but no i don't think it's
transitory so i think a lot and i bring
that up because
i think that's the same with risk and
there are a lot of people that will
define risk differently by and large
based off of the time horizon so if you
were to ask me if the stock market fell
20
and stayed there for three years is that
a risk a lot of people would say yeah
that's a huge risk that's an enormous
like catastrophic risk i personally
would say that's not a risk at all and
the reason is because my goals
lie 50 years in the future so what's
going to happen in the next three years
i could i could honestly care less
that's really how i think but but that
would not be my answer if i was a 90
year old retired widow on a fixed income
then i'd have a very different answer
for you so i think
summing all that up risk is just the
odds that something will prevent you
from achieving your goals but the nuance
is that everyone has very different
goals and aspirations and time horizons
so everyone thinks about risk
differently
the takeaway from that is most investing
debates where people are arguing with
each other is this a risk is that a risk
should i buy this stock is the market
going to go up next week by and large
those debates are not actually debates
it's people with different risk
tolerances and different time horizons
talking over each other talking over one
another
and that's why so i think to me the most
important part about risk is that the
definition is different for everyone my
definition is going to be different from
yours which is different from anyone
else who's listening and it's not
because we disagree with each other it's
just because we're different people with
different goals and different ages and
different family situations etc etc
and so risk is a very personalized
calculation for everyone whether that's
in investing or other areas of your life
one of the illustrations i enjoyed from
your book i think you used google as an
example i wasn't a somewhat arbitrary
example but you
you highlighted the different questions
or considerations you might have
if you were considering buying google
based on different time horizons right
ten years two years six months day
trader something like that yeah and
it was it's a very
helpful exercise to kind of review
how
the game you choose to play determines
the definitions or the parameters for a
lot of these terms that we throw around
very loosely like risk right yep so
let's let's talk about let's talk about
games i was texting with a friend of
mine as a very good investor i'll leave
his name out of it for now but i asked
him if he had any questions for you
and
so he his map of reality i'm
paraphrasing here is as a journalist
historian being paid to write
interesting things related to
investing right so look so the questions
that he has are are more related to
being a skilled content creator
in this new tech world so
here's one question and this is related
to
observing that you are very active on
twitter
so zooming out what is this fintwit game
that you're playing and what are the
rules here's how i think about content
in general whether this is twitter or
writing writing an article writing a
book i am i call this selfish writing
i'm writing for an audience of one and
that is me the only thing that i write
the only thing that i tweet the only
thing the articles that i write the
books that i write i just write through
the lens of do i personally think this
is interesting and if the answer is yes
i make a leap of faith that other people
might think it's interesting as well and
i think a lot of writers get into
trouble by asking themselves
what does my audience want to read what
will other people think is interesting
and i think that leads to kind of like
this bastardization of finance where
it's like oh this tweet got a million
likes like yeah but it's so corny it's
so salesy even if it did really well
like like you you can't tell me that you
actually the author think this is
interesting i know it performed well but
you don't think it's interesting and
also what when you the writer are most
interested in when i'm only looking
through the lens of do i morgan think
this is interesting that's when you do
your best work of course because that's
when it doesn't feel like work it's like
i'm writing this article because i think
it's this topic is really interesting
and i would want to read it written in
this way that's the game that i play is
just trying to be really selfish in that
endeavor and just ask what do i think is
interesting and if i think it's
interesting other people will as well
okay
so let's let's take a closer look at the
playing field so twitter is one medium
that you engage with
very heavily one arena
who would you consider
i'm picking an arbitrary range here but
like three to five of the top players in
fintwood financial twitter
who
you pay attention to and why you pay
attention to them
i will expand that slightly out of
fintwit but two that really stick out
and these are very well known names one
is james clear who wrote a book called
atomic habits and the other is mark
manson who wrote the book the subtle art
of not giving a [ __ ]
both of them do uh something that i
think is really rare which is that they
don't tweet very much they maybe tweet
once a day but it's very good it's very
thoughtful it's it's thought provoking
and they tweet one away and then they
back off until the next day i think
that's that's also something that i've
tried to emulate and i think the people
that just kind of flood the feed with
every little brain fart that might come
into their head and just dump it into
twitter and hit publish some of them are
are interesting and entertaining but it
can get old after a while i think the
people who have done really well that
i've admired have a level of restraint
on twitter of only putting out things
that they think are are really worth
reading i think naval is also pretty
good at that in terms of just putting
out something maybe once a day maybe
he's like twice a week at this point but
it's good like it's real when he tweets
you're like oh i gotta i gotta look at
this this is interesting so james mark
and naval i think have in my view played
the game really well
josh brown he quit twitter about a year
ago but i thought he was the king who's
josh brown he is the ceo of rid holt's
wealth management he's on cnbc almost
every day and he was someone who would
tweet probably 20 30 times a day but
he's so funny and he's so insightful and
so smart
that it was worth reading every time so
it was it was a loss for twitter to see
him go
i think derek thompson from the atlantic
i've mentioned him a couple times and
someone who i really admire is just
being a really multi-disciplinary
thinker and whenever he puts something
out
it's from completely different fields he
had a podcast recently on
on autocracy in belarus and then the
next day he could be writing about
omicron he'd be writing about the stock
market he's so well-rounded in his
thinking that it's always interesting
it's always fresh you never know what's
going to come from him those are those
are just a few people who i really
admire here
so let's take a take a lateral move to
some some maybe related territory and i
remember my promise earlier to people
that we would come back to buffett and
monger so i have not forgotten for those
who are like goddamn at ferris i've not
forgotten i take notes as we do these
things
so
who are some investors you respect the
hell out of but would never try to
emulate are there any people who come to
mind
i mean definitely it and monger for one
just this them in in general i you
here's here's kind of the twist on this
i'm not sure there's any investor who i
admire that i would try to emulate and i
think the reason that is is because i
admire them because they have a really
unique skill and by definition most
people including myself don't have that
skill another thing is that a lot of
people who are really successful at
investing were successful in one era but
maybe not necessarily this era so you
can really admire what they did and how
they thought and the risks that they
took in that time but it would never
work today benjamin graham the great
investor who wrote the book the
intelligent investor he's like the
godfather of investing if you tried to
put benjamin graham's techniques to work
today you would fail so incredibly
hard so miserably if you were putting
together like the actual formulas that
he laid out in his book you would fail
miserably so there's really not anyone
that i would really try to emulate i'm a
fairly passive investor and john balgo
who started vanguard i think is probably
the most admirable because it was so
selfless what he did vanguard a lot of
people don't even know this vanguard is
owned by the people who own vanguard
mutual there's no vanguard shareholders
there's no profits there's no dividends
that are played to the owners vanguard
has was made for the benefit of the
people who own the etfs the people who
own the mutual funds and john bogle did
not make that much money for himself
because of that and you could almost
think that like vanguard's low fees like
the amount that you saved in fees is
money that could have gone to john bogle
and john pogel's estate that didn't it's
like he's like this undercover
philanthropist of of finance that i
really admire just because there's so
few other people like that and i think
someone like uh james simons who we
mentioned earlier i think in every field
there's only one person
whose
claim to fame whose competitive
advantage is i'm smarter than everyone
else in tech for 20 or 30 years that
person was bill gates and i think in
finance for the last 20 or 30 years that
person has been james simons who is he's
like the only person in the field who
can say well if you if you ask them the
question what is your competitive
advantage they can say i'm just smarter
than everyone else only one person can
say that and it's james simons
so it's if you look at what renaissance
technology has has done and just the
results that they've accumulated and the
consistency of what they've done
it's it's like lebron james times
michael jordan times
tiger woods to the power of michaela
schifrin it's like it's just like such a
different universe compared to what
anyone else has done that it's just it's
astounding to watch
for a fun and fascinating romp through
different investing styles and very big
personalities
the book more money than god by
say sebastian maliby am i getting that
right something that's right is is very
entertaining
also not a whole lot of styles you would
want to try to emulate unless that is
your sport and you are in there
any other investors besides jim simons
come to mind and the names you've
already mentioned who you think are
truly exceptional now they could i will
expand investor to mean capital
allocator right so it could also be
a ceo of a company
but
i'll let you pick who you may pick
there's a value investor named monish
probably who is not very well known he's
a fairly small investor he's capped the
size of his fund at a fairly low level
so he's not a household name he's not
like even within investing circles not
many people know who he is his returns
are incredibly good and he's just the
nicest
wisest fun to be around guy
that that i've that i've met in a long
time like i really look up to him not
just as an investor but just as a person
just how he's situated his life what he
aspires to be how he lives his life is
someone who i've really looked up to for
a long time there's
someone who lots of listeners will be
familiar with brent b short who's very
active on twitter as well is an
incredibly successful investor he won't
say that he will deny that but he really
is and he too is just
one of the nicest kindest funniest
people who i've met and most of the time
when he and i talk it's nothing to do
about investing we just talk about life
and our kids and our spouses and whatnot
so i think most of the people who i
really admire as investors it's more
that i admire just how they've lived
their lives and their general life
philosophies and their investing
philosophy stems from that that's true
for for buffett as well
actually there's an interesting thing
about buffett which is that it was so
easy to admire him and still is but when
the book the snowball came out which is
a biography written about buffett by an
author named alice schroeder and it came
out i want to say 2009 something like
that it really makes clear the case that
buffett has not lived a perfect life by
any means and in a lot of instances his
family life has been a disaster i think
that's the right word to use i don't
it's kind of kind of rude to say that
but i think it's really true in some
ways it's good to hear that that like
everyone puts their pants on one leg at
a time in the morning everyone is human
everyone deals with the ups and the
downs of of living a life and that he's
a human and also that a lot of the
reason that his family life was troubled
at times is because he was had a
singular devotion in life which was
picking the best stocks and everything
else came second to that everything from
his family on down came second to that
in a way that a lot of people including
myself at one point said i want to be
warren buffett i want to be the next
warren buffett but then you re you read
about what it took to get there and i'm
like no i i want to stay 10 miles away
from that that's a really important
insight to learn is that a lot of these
people who you admire
the reason that you admire them is
because they're so successful and that
success that they had had enormous costs
associated with it that are easy to
ignore and when i look at that it's like
i can look at pieces of buffett's life
that i admire and pieces of jim simon's
life that i admire but i don't want to
be them because that mega success had so
many costs attached to it that i want to
avoid in my life that's been a really
important observation too for me
there's also a slippery slope
i shouldn't say slippery slope there's
an ease with which
you can conflate
skills and attributes with investors
very easily right and what i mean by
that is
no one looks at say michael phelps and
says all right i just need to swim more
so i can i can grow taller and get more
flexible ankles and huge feet like
michael phelps they know that's not
going to happen right you can't those
are not trainable
attributes uh those are things you're
born with and similarly you might look
at say buffett and you're like oh that
looks like a normal guy right looks like
a grandpa aw shucks right i could i
could i could learn to do what grandpa
does
but when i read i have not read the
snowball but i read an earlier biography
unauthorized as i think they all were by
roger lowenstein or stein i never know
that's going to be pronounced the making
of an american capitalist and i read
this decades ago but the story that
really stuck out to me and i'm probably
getting this wrong but
someone on the internet will correct me
i remember his his meaning warren's
routine was to work at the office and
then come home and basically just walk
straight upstairs and begin reading
like s1 filings or
you know annual reports of one type or
another quarterly reports
and that was his routine and one day
he came home
after work and i want to say his son but
one of his kids was like splayed out at
the bottom of the stairs and had clearly
like fallen down the stairs and he just
stepped over this child and walked up to
his office
to read reports like it didn't even
register to attend to his child and i
was like okay
i am not programmed that way like that
yeah that is different out of the box
hardwiring that i will not be able to
train myself
to possess in the same way that
uh you know the mistakes uh a lot of the
mistakes that i've made in investing
have been actually almost all of them
have been selling at the wrong times
and
which is why i find a lot of these risk
assessments that might be given to you
by a broker or a wealth manager or
who knows somebody who's who's who's
hopefully got your best interests at
heart and they say you would feel
comfortable with a like 15 decrease in
your portfolio's value in one quarter
five percent you know one percent 20 30
and you just have no [ __ ] idea until
it happens right because i remember i
had
at the time this is 2007 2008
there were a few decisions that i'd made
beforehand i had bought my first home
in san jose
with oops an adjustable rate mortgage
2007 and i had i had also a few years
before
plowed a ton of my net worth at the time
into amazon and i had very high
conviction around it i don't remember
the price i mean somebody could look it
up
you know 2006 2000
late 2005 something like that
and
i i got hammered in the housing market
and then when the sky started falling
intellectually i knew that i shouldn't
sell
does that make sense like i'd read the
books
i was like longitudinally
things are gonna be okay the
fundamentals of the business haven't
changed i feel like i'm i have a pretty
good read on the technical or
technological trends i'm living in
silicon valley
i everyone i know is using amazon more
and more with each
each subsequent year
but every time i turned on the news it
was chicken little and the sky was
falling and eventually i was like
these people seem smart i'm a kid what
the [ __ ] do i know and then i sold the
amazon right it was not the right
decision
and
i tell that story just to draw the
contrast between
what i did and what i suspect warren
buffett would have done had he been in
my position he would not have behaved
the same way and it wouldn't have been
arrived at purely through logic the guy
is just built differently well here's
here's one counter to that you're
generally right but here's the counter
to this
february of 2020 rolls around there's a
new virus that's gonna rile the world
economy what did buffett do do you know
the answer to that what he did you tell
me you're gonna have a better read on
this he dumped his entire portfolio of
airline stocks at a huge loss that's
what he did yeah here's what's crazy
about this two weeks before that maybe
it was a week before it was a very short
period of time before he went on cnbc
when it was starting to look like maybe
the market was getting toppy and someone
asked him like warren what would you do
if the market starts falling and he says
he laughs and he says i'll tell you what
i'm not going to do i'm not going to
sell two weeks later he sold all of his
airline stocks at the when this virus
hit now you can say that that was
actually not a mistake even though the
majority of them have regained almost
all of their value you can say that was
not a mistake because the the
possibility of a complete catastrophic
wipeout particularly in airlines with
kovid was was there so you could say
like that was actually the right thing
to do
but even buffett in this situation
when when the world's starting falling
apart he panicked and he did not buy he
did not buy anything of significant
value with with big numbers during that
huge market decline even for him i'm
saying it's much easier said than done i
had my own story about this
in the early days of covet morgan can i
ask you to
bookmark that don't lose your place but
i want to interject with a question and
that is
do you think that
early
earlier career buffett would have also
sold and the reason i ask is that i saw
an interview with monger from
i don't know a year or two ago maybe it
was actually more like two or three
years ago and he said too many people
have their entire life savings and are
depending on berkshire
yeah which seemed to imply and i'm
paraphrasing
that that was in a sense leading them to
behave in ways
or make decisions that they would not
have made
earlier in their careers
what do you think
here's what's so interesting about what
happened in march of 2020 in the early
days of covid which is that if the
government had not done trillions of
dollars in stimulus if the fed had not
done trillion dollars in stimulus if
there was not a vaccine you can go on
down these possibilities that were very
realistic possibilities i think we would
honestly be looking at something that
would be worse than the great depression
right now i don't even think that's a
bold statement it had the potential to
be absolutely catastrophic
so when you have buffett selling and not
buying because he wants to bank up more
cash i actually get that i think if you
were to make the 10 most likely outcomes
of kovid i think economically we ended
up with absolutely the best one and it's
easy for us in hindsight to look back
and say oh you should have bought in
march of 2020 and it actually was not
that obvious back then that that's what
you should have done that's one thing
the other thing that's so different
about it is that
you know buffett has probably invested
through i don't know 10 recessions
something like that but all of those
were financial recessions there were
things going on in the economy that
caused recession this was a biological
disaster it was a completely different
set of fears
that people didn't really know what was
going to happen next i i don't think
there was any real playbook that even
something or somebody who has 80 years
experience could really look at and say
oh here's here's what you do whenever
there's a pandemic that's threatening
the global economy there's not really
much insight into what to do with that
so i i think in in different recessions
the other thing that's important too is
that even in 2008 during the financial
crisis buffett did do some buying but
actually not that much he actually
didn't put that much capital to work
even in 2008. the last time that like
the economy completely lost itself and
buffett put a lot of money to work was
like the 1970s that's i think that's
that's a true statement it's been it's
been quite a while since he's put tons
of money to work when the economy fell
apart some of that is just how his and
his style has evolved over time rather
than being like a tactical
asset allocator he just wants to buy
good businesses and hold them for a long
time and the idea of like buying when
there's blood in the streets has less
relevance to him today than it did 50
years ago so that's part of it but i
think for everyone and buffett is human
that when you get to a situation like
this it's so easy
to respond to risk in ways that you
never thought you would and i'll tell
you my personal story from this my wife
and i were for a long time the plan was
we were going to sell our house in
virginia in april of 2020. well before
kova that was the plan now in march of
2020 i woke up one morning at two in the
morning and went holy [ __ ] there might
not be a market to sell our house
in in april the market just might not
exist them all them or the banks might
go bankrupt the world just might not
exist and if that's the case it's going
to make our move to seattle where we we
live now much trickier so i called up
our real estate agent and i said hey i
know the plan is to sell the house in
april but i won't put the house on the
market today today i want to put the
house in the market right now and he
said morgan don't panic and i
interrupted him and i said oh i am
panicked you are looking panic in the
face right now this is panic i am
totally panicked
and i am someone who does this stuff for
a living and write about not panicking
for a living and look the the sale all
worked out and i didn't sell stocks like
i really didn't it wasn't it didn't feel
like a panic
but it was so it's so easy when the
world is going well and everything is
all butterflies and rainbows to imagine
to yourself
and to ask to answer the hypothetical
question how would you feel if the
market fell 30
and when the world is going well you
answer that question by imagining a
world in which everything is the same
except stock prices are 30 lower and in
that world you're like oh that would be
great that would be an opportunity but
that's not what happens in the real
world in the real world the market falls
30 percent because there's a terrorist
attack that no one saw coming or wall
street is about to collapse or there's a
virus that might kill you and your
family and in that context you think
completely differently and that's why
people's ability to say i will be greedy
when others are fearful is so much
greater than your most people's ability
to actually do it that's true for me
it's true for you i think it's true for
buffett as well
absolutely a couple of
footnotes on
several of the names that have come up
uh so i believe you wrote about this in
your book
and it was something i did not know so
benjamin graham right
if not a deity certainly a minor deity
in many of the investing circles uh
certainly the self-described sort of
value investing
side of things
is it true am i recalling correctly that
a
a bulk of his
career returns came from concentration
in geico am i getting that right
that's true though the last page of
benjamin grimm's book the intelligent
investor tells this little tale about an
investor who earned basically his entire
career success off of one investment and
that one investment broke every rule
that this investor had laid out and then
kind of in the last paragraph on the
last page of his book he says by the way
that investor is me
and if you look at benjamin graham's
track record
his career track record is incredibly
good and if you remove geico it's
average and and like i mentioned geico
by graham's own saying breaks every rule
that he just laid out in that book
like to buy it and so that's that's an
interesting a really interesting thing
is like not only was it one company but
it's one company that broke all the
rules so if you're reading that book and
looking for rules to follow like by
definition you are not going to achieve
benjamin graham's success and so i think
that's that's really telling and i don't
know what the takeaway from that is if
you could say well then clearly he's
just lucky if if all of his success is
was due to one company that broke the
rules you could say he's just lucky the
other thing you could say is that's just
how capitalism works and that's true for
buffett it's true for a lot of people
that if they make 100 investments you're
going to make the huge majority of your
money on probably five of them that's
true for anyone that's even true if
you're investing in an index fund that
within the index most of the games are
gonna come from
five percent of the companies that you
invest in that's always the case i think
it just kind of changes how
people view success though like if your
view of success is that every stock that
warren buffett or shamath or
jim chanos or you know all these like
these big name investors that every time
they make an investment then it's clear
that that company is going to be a
winner and that's just not how this
success plays out at all that even among
the top names the best investors over
time the majority of the picks that they
make do not do very well
and the reason that they're so
successful is because one or two or
maybe five investments they've made are
ultra home runs people associate that
with venture capital that's how it works
in vc but it's actually true in all
stages of investing the stat that i'll
share with you here is that if you look
at
the russell 3000 index which is an index
of large public stocks in the united
states over time from i think 1980 to
2010 40 of the stocks in this large cap
like mom and pop index 40 of the
companies went out of business
not not merged not bought by but they
went bankrupt 40 of them but the index
did very well because seven percent of
components were huge winners it was like
amazon microsoft netflix those companies
so even in a boring old index fund
almost half the companies are going to
go out of business but you'll still do
well because a few do very well and so
that was true and i think the more
successful you are the more you see that
even at a company like like apple or
whatnot like what percentage of apple's
success is the iphone it's enormous but
they've experimented with dozens of
different products over time amazon has
experimented with the fire phone which
is a total flop and they've done things
in music which were flops they've done
all these flops but they've also done
prime and aws which matters more than
anything else so almost anywhere you
look you will see that a tiny number of
activities apply for the majority of
success and it's so hard to wrap your
head around that when you're trying to
emulate these people who you look up to
and admire
yeah you really got to pay attention and
look at the under-reported
analyses
and i i remember learning
at one point this is just a few years
ago and please correct me if i'm getting
this wrong i i heard it from someone i
consider a very reliable
source but he told me that you know
monger effectively has three
concentrated or primary positions is
berkshire hathaway
costco
and then money with a
chinese
fund manager who
has derived a lot of his returns from
tech investments
in east asia and i i don't know what
that pie chart breaks down to right in
the sense that if it's 99
berkshire i don't know how much you can
infer or conclude from what i just said
in the same way that if someone's like
well so and so like peter thiel invested
in my company and i'm like how much did
he invest if he put in 25k
that's
literally like dropping a penny on the
street for
for peter maybe it was done through his
office and who the hell knows like the
signal may not be very strong
but
i the the disproportionate sort of
tail
tail risk or i should say like
asymmetric return
reward and punishment is a big deal one
example of this too that i love was from
walt disney who back in the 1920s and
30s was making all of these cartoons
that people loved and they were great
but they were all losing money they were
all commercial failures and he was on
the verge of bankruptcy and his whole
career was gonna was gonna be over and
shut down the studio and then snow white
and the seven doors came out and it was
such
a huge mega blockbuster success that all
of a sudden he had enough money to keep
the studio open and to make more films
but if you look at walt disney's
commercial success in those years the
early decades and you take out snow
white it's a it's a disaster so even
even among like the highest talents in
any field that we look at like that
you're going to see that tales drive
everything it's just so hard to wrap
your head around that when you're trying
to emulate these people well i imagine
you know a lot of people listening are
gonna say well [ __ ] this sounds kind of
like a hopeless task right because if
you're
if you're betting on or hoping to
emulate someone who found a
golden willy wonka ticket i don't know
how to form a strategy around that but
i would imagine there are certain
certain base principles you can take
away if you're looking at
whether it's venture very successful
venture capitalists who have been
successful for a long period of time
right because you can get really lucky
and hit the midas list and look like a
genius for a short period of time but
people who have just for decades been
successful and there is a selection bias
because the best tend to then see better
and better deals first but
just putting that aside you also see the
same thing in
say a book like
bringing down the house by
ben metric or mitch rich i apologize ben
i've forgotten how to say your last name
which was later made into 21 about this
i believe it was a team out of mit that
developed a system for counting cards in
blackjack
and one of the sort of underlying
slash rules was having sufficient
bankroll
to
continue playing through a string of
improbable bad luck
right so in terms of bet sizing there
are
certain
principles perhaps that's the best word
i can come up with right now that you
that you could pull from
a disney or one of these other examples
that could be translated to some type of
investment approach that people could
begin to wrap their heads around
anyway i'm just thinking out loud as we
as we go through this
yeah no i always think like when you
have these idols in any field doesn't
have to be in investing you just want to
ask what can you emulate and for all of
them you can't emulate their luck you
probably can't emulate their super
special talent or
or intellect but there are things among
them that you can emulate for buffett i
think the thing that i've tried to think
about that's been so successful for him
the driver to his success that hopefully
i can have some chance of of repeating
is just time it's just the time horizon
that's something i can't i can't mimic
his intelligence i can't mimic the
market conditions that he had but if i
can stay invested for the next 50 years
that's as close as i'm gonna get to
actually learning something from him
that i can take away there's this other
there's this great interview with with
michael moritz who is the head of
sequoia sequoia and he was asked
by charlie rose he said why has sequoia
been so successful like and how have you
succeeded for 40 years which is the
amount of time that they've been winning
in in this industry and and what he said
was quote
we've always been scared of going out of
business we've always been paranoid
we've always
thought that what we've earned yesterday
is not guaranteed tomorrow and this is
for someone who is a multi-billionaire
who has the most success of anyone else
in the history of this industry and
that's what he's thinking about every
day is
is paranoia and fear if there's one
person in the industry that like
deserves to be cocky about their skill
it's someone like him and it's the
opposite he's terrified he's paranoid i
think that idea of only the paranoid
survive is another thing that like you
and i tim can learn from that even if we
don't have the deal flow of sequoia
that you and i can can take something
away from that so i think just whenever
you're looking at these people that's
that's something to do particularly when
you go back to what we were talking
about earlier of like i don't want to be
buffett even if i could i
the life that he's living is not
appealing to me in the slightest so when
i'm looking at someone like that and
trying to learn or trying to copy them
it's like well i actually don't want to
be them so what is something from their
life that i can kind of pick and choose
that i have
the chance of replicating myself that is
still going to align with the life that
i want to live and that's much different
than what most of what goes on which is
just like blind copycatting of investors
who are out there
yeah for sure
you know
the fear of going going broke or going
out of business let's double click on
that for a second so i remember getting
advice from a very successful investor
at one point who
i think would put himself squarely in
the value investing camp he's been very
successful for decades
does not care about the glitz and the
glam and the flash of the latest
crypto fill in the blank has absolutely
zero interest so very much
a
a student of an acolyte of the
buffett monger
side of things
and he said just
do not take short positions do not short
and do not use leverage he's like if you
just avoid those two things chances are
you're not going to go totally out of
business you're not going to go totally
bankrupt there's this quote from from
buffett where he's talking about
leverage and he said if you're smart you
don't need it and if you're dumb you
shouldn't be using it
that's that's a good way to summarize
what what leverage is in investing now
then then you have and i'm bringing this
up because i think it's very hard for
people to parse fact from fiction or
signal from noise in the financial press
or even just financial discussion right
like who to listen to is is a difficult
to answer question for a lot of people
it's difficult for me too sometimes
right and i've just realized that if you
read anything like you should skip to
the bottom and just read the disclaimers
first because if they're just like
shilling their posit you know talking
their book and shilling their position
then you want to know that before you
read 10 pages
but on the flip side then
i read this piece in the wall street
journal that was sent to me by someone
which
had the headline
buy borrow die are you familiar with
this at all the buy borrow and die
approach
i'm not familiar with it but i think i
could put it together you just you go
into a bunch of debt and then die is
that what it is yeah basically that it's
like a it's like a sort of dynastic
approach to wealth transference whereby
you never you basically get everything
that you
need and want through leverage right i
mean obviously of risk of margin calls
and things like that as
we saw to dramatic effect during
covet certainly some people were just
overextended and got their faces ripped
off including some very very famous
families i want to name
but
how do you make sense of
conflicting
opposed advice from
seemingly
intelligent rational parties on both
sides i think you have to parse the
difference between what works on a
chalkboard and what works in real life
many years ago there was a study put out
by a group of researchers at yale and
what they showed is that their advice
was everyone every single investor
should use 100 leverage in their 401k
they should lever up as much as they
possibly can in their 401k and they
showed historically that that was the
right thing to do because even if you
got completely wiped out even if you
your portfolio went to zero because of
your leverage as long as you picked
yourself up the next day and bought
stocks with two times leverage over time
you would you would earn like an extra
three percentage points of return and
they were dead serious in this report
and the math all works out it works on
the chalkboard on the spreadsheet
they're right it's the right thing to do
in the real world
people would not work there's no real
world in which someone would watch their
retirement portfolio go to zero and then
the next day keep doing the same thing
that's just not how people's heads work
and so
there's a lot of things in finance that
that look smart and sound smart and the
numbers add up and it's just completely
opposed to how the real world works i
i'd write in the book that the
difference between being rational and
reasonable and there are a lot of things
that investors do that are not rational
but i think they're perfectly reasonable
and they align with how people's heads
work one of which i would i would say is
there's this well-documented home bias
with investors where you know by and
large people who live in america only
own u.s stocks and people who live in
germany only own german stocks in japan
so on people own the stocks that are
closest to where they live which is not
rational at all it's not irrational to
think like the best stocks are the ones
that are closest to your house that's
crazy but that's how people invest and
it's not rational but it's actually very
reasonable if taking the leap of faith
of investing your life savings in these
companies if it's easier to do that when
you're most familiar with them that's
totally a reasonable thing to do
and so i think that difference between
reasonable and rational is really
important i read about in the book too
that my wife and i don't have a mortgage
on our house which is the worst
financial decision we've ever made and i
would never try to justify it on a
spreadsheet because i can't it's a
terrible it's a terrible financial
decision but it's been the best money
decision that we've ever made it's given
us more joy and pleasure than anything
that we've done with our money even
though it's the worst financial decision
we've ever made just because it gives us
a sense of independence and security and
particularly when we're raising our kids
like this is our house it's not the
bank's house this is our house i cannot
rationalize that tim on a spreadsheet i
can't but it makes me happy and so that
that difference between the spreadsheet
in the real world is so important
everyone thinks about it a little bit
differently but i i turn my nose a
little bit at the academics who just
live inside of excel and think that's
how the world works and i respect a lot
more the kind of gritty people on the
street that understand how the real
world works and how people's brains
works what makes them tick and how
things actually play out
yeah
and i should also volunteer
that maybe four years ago five years ago
i was having a conversation with a very
financially successful friend of mine
who's also done a very
a great job of crafting an unusual
just trying to think of how to tiptoe
around some of his adventures exciting
life for himself that
is is just quintessentially him right
it's like unapologetically non-consensus
and he seems to just have a great time
in life and he's he's made a lot of
very
deliberate decisions and i i wanted to
get some advice from him about something
and he asked me to lay out
what my current kind of balance sheet
looked like and i laid it out and he
said
why do you have this mortgage left or
this amount left on your mortgage on
your house and i said well
blah blah blah and i gave him the kind
of spreadsheet justification right like
interest rates are low it's basically
free money blood
i can take that money and do blah blah
blah and he said just pay it off he said
just having the peace of mind that no
matter what you have a house that cannot
be taken away
is going to do more for your ability to
sleep at night than anything else he's
like it doesn't make sense
mathematically
but
pay off the mortgage and he was right
psychologically the payoff was
tremendous and
i guess if we think of
investing or one way to think of
investing being
allocating capital to improve your
quality of life then it is a good
investment right to pay it off totally
makes sense i'm not recommending that
for everybody this is just my own story
but i ended up
in the same place as yourself for that
reason i also know a lot of people for
whom that would be a terrible decision
they could not live with themselves if
they knew that they were leaving money
on the table so it works for me and my
wife and you it sounds like and other
people it wouldn't and that's where i
get down to like all all this is just
personal and whatever works for you and
there's something about money where that
that can irk people like there's some
people when i tell them i don't have a
mortgage they they get angry at it
because i've it's such a bad financial
decision and in a way that like other
things in life don't work like that if
if you said i like classical music i
might say cool that's great i don't but
that's fine i don't think any less of
you i'm not going to argue with you
about it's just that's your taste this
is mine and but for financial decisions
people really don't like that because
and i think those are people who only
view it as a spreadsheet endeavor versus
using capital to give yourself a better
life like you mentioned
let's hop back to
jason zweig's piece
this is from august 7th 2020
discussing
your book and
i want to
pull out a contrast and styles and
explore this a little bit you'll
recognize this of course
so
the first
example this is person a ronald reed
i'm guessing that's how you say his last
name
to ronald read however money was a
possibility so i'm reversing the award
here mr reed spent decades pumping gas
and working as a janitor in brattleboro
vermont after he died in 2014 at the age
of 92 his estate was able to give more
than six million dollars to local
charities because he had scrimped and
put every spare penny into stocks that
he held for decades no college degree no
training no background no formal
experience no connections
but nonetheless massively outperformed
many professional investors all right so
i'm going to leave
mr reed at that for now
the contrast
is something you saw yourself a
technology multi-millionaire handed a
hotel valet thousands of dollars in cash
to go buy a fistful of gold coins at a
nearby nearby jewelry store sorry this
story's just
i can see it i can see it in my mind's
eye the executive then flung the coins
worth about a thousand dollars a piece
into the pacific ocean one at a time
skipping them across the water like flat
rocks quote just for fun end quote to
that man money was a play thing and then
in parentheses he later went broke
totally true story it was it was the
craziest thing valentine's there's this
guy who won't say his name but he was
very well he was worth several hundred
million dollars and he was just a
complete maniac and his relationship
with money was astounding usually carry
around this stack of hundred dollar
bills that i swear was four or five
inches thick and he would just walk up
to strangers and pinch a little bit off
the top and just hand it to them just to
see the reaction on their face and he
did this all the time
and and he had all these crazy things
including that the story i tell in the
book he told us one day he he pinched
off a thick stack of 100 bills and he
said go to the jewelry store and get us
some coins some gold coins and we one of
my colleagues did it and he came back
and him and his friends just sat there
skipping them in the pacific ocean just
cackling to each other like who can make
it the farthest and they're throwing a
thousand dollars thousand dollars a
thousand dollars and they just thought
it was the funniest thing in the world
and then years later i found out that
this guy went broke we went bankrupt and
that's not that's not surprising but it
was just astounding to watch how some
people
really smart successful people deal with
money so one lesson we could take from
that i mean there are many lessons we
can take from this right
uh
if your valet take the money and run i'm
kidding it's a joke
but one lesson we could take is slow and
steady
wins the race right substance over
smoke and and
razzmatazz
that would be one moral of the story
that you can get you can build wealth
very effectively without doing anything
fancy without being jim simons simply by
being consistent and holding for a long
period of time
i think that's that's a good way to
summarize it yeah yeah so that's one
now
i think
for purposes of the contrast it makes
sense that you would have these two
extremes right but there's a lot in
between and so
one
question that comes to me when i i hear
a story like this also is
would mr reed
have been
would he have considered his his life
better lived
had he taken some of that money
and used it to enjoy himself or do
something while he was still above
ground
or not at 92. yeah there's probably one
regret that i have from the book is that
i kind of framed it like ronald reed was
my idol and i i didn't i didn't mean to
make that point at all because someone
who lives
literally a very impoverished life and
is sweet and is mopping the floors at a
gas station and then dies with millions
of dollars i don't aspire to that's not
the life that i want to live to me the
whole point was
the skills that you need to generate
wealth are not the ivy league education
and becoming a partner of goldman sachs
this janitor was able to do it but i
i don't personally admire the life that
he lived i want to live a good life and
buy the things that i want and have a
nice house and a nice car and treat my
kids well and go on good vacations and
travel the whole nine yards
the whole point of that was just showing
that the skills that you need do not
come from the traditional sources that
we that we associate financial success
with got it all right so i have a
question for you as a
a researcher professional observer
i don't want to say of finance because
it's more than that right but i imagine
including
the example of these guys
handing a stack of money to go buy gold
coins you've observed wealthy people
whether directly or through reading
and
so on
for a while now and
i'm gonna lead into this with a recent
conversation i overheard two wealthy
people were having a conversation about
basically how much to save for how long
and
both of them had been
sort of born into very
moderate circumstances like lower middle
class or even
being poor
so so one was saving everything kind of
until the very end to hand off to
future generations and the other the
other person said well
you might want to consider
spending or using more of that money now
because there's there's only so much you
can't take it with you and there's only
so much money you can give to your kids
before you ruin them
and i never heard it quite put that way
but i grew up on long island as a town
in the hamptons so i worked restaurants
as a busboy and just
you know various low
status low-paying jobs
in a resort town where you get to see
the best and the worst but mostly the
worst of manhattan
yep kind of see and be seen
crowd there are some great people right
i've many of my best friends are are in
new york city but nonetheless
saw some really horrible behavior right
and so this is a very roundabout way of
asking
if you kind of scan over your
experiences observing the wealthy and so
on if you look at examples where their
kids aren't [ __ ] entitled [ __ ] how do
they achieve that
i hate that i'm quoting buffett again i
don't want to do this ad nauseum for the
whole podcast but he has a great quote
on wealth where he says he wants to
leave his kids enough money that they
can do anything but not so much money
that they could do nothing so i think
that's really the key and that's how i
think about my own kids who are very
young but when my wife and i think like
how do we want to use whatever savings
that we have to benefit them
giving them a safety net but not a fuel
is hey that's what my parents did for
myself and my siblings we i always knew
when i was a teenager and in my early
20s i always knew they would be there if
i fell on my face and they would like i
would never just completely fail i'd
never be homeless i'd never they'd
always catch me but they were never
going to be a fuel they're never just
going to give me money just to just to
make my life better that was never going
to be the case
and so knowing that they were going to
be there but knowing that i had to make
it on my own was so important for me
that's what i want to do for my own kids
i think if there's anything that's like
that
i think that rule is probably the
closest that you get to having very
wealthy kids who are not [ __ ] as you
put it which is which is which is a
great way to put it not to get too
technical but it's also just so
there's a great book that i read a
couple years ago and i reread it last
year it's one of my favorite books it's
called fortunes children and it's about
how the vanderbilt heirs spent their
money
and blew their fortune and cornelius
vanderbilt was the richest man in the
world if you adjusted for inflation he
was worth like 400 billion dollars wow
and within i think three or four
generations there was nothing left they
spent everything and they actually
didn't give that much to charity either
they were not they did not do that much
philanthropy they just blew that money
and a couple things stick out from the
book one is that
virtually every heir i don't think
there's a single counter example to this
they were all miserable they all they
were all depressed they were all anxious
they were all like none of them really
lived life that anyone would want to
read and say oh i wish i could live that
life they were all miserable and i think
another part of this is that none of
them were allowed to become their own
people their job in life was to be a
vanderbilt heir and they were never
allowed to have their own personality to
really have their own pursuits or if
even if they did their own pursuits it
was never going to live up to what their
grandfather did and therefore why even
try and all of them were just living in
the shadow of this this ancestor that
they had
and so i think when i look at that it's
like you really see how money can ruin
people i thought about this myself with
my kids of like let's say my wife and i
go out and buy a porsche we don't have
one but let's just use that
hypothetically but we buy a porsche and
then let's say that my daughter wants to
be a kindergarten teacher and she's
driving a toyota corolla because that's
what she can afford as a kindergarten
teacher is she always gonna feel like
she's in the shadow of her parents like
she did not eclipse what her parents did
even if she has a more noble job than i
do and a more benefici a job that
benefits society more than i do is she
gonna feel like she never reaches that
point because of how my wife and i
decided to live our lives i don't want
to do that as a parent and i think about
that a lot too is like how can i live a
good life and have a good house and nice
stuff but make sure that i'm not
leaving the bar too high for my children
if they go into another career that
doesn't pay as well
that's a tough thing i don't know if
there's any easy answers to that but i
think about that a lot of like how can
you
become a safety net but never a fuel and
i'll tell you something that i didn't
really realize a couple years ago was
that the instinct to be a fuel when you
are a parent is really strong the
instinct to say hey i'm fortunate enough
to have some savings how can i use it to
benefit my kids and open doors for my
kids and push them along and put them on
third base is tough to fight against
that because every cell in your body as
a parent says you should do that i was
really hoping that the book you're going
to recommend would be called
how to raise kids who aren't [ __ ] or
something really on the nose that's book
number two it's coming yeah please
someone write that book you can have the
title
just just write something kind in the
acknowledgements
fortunes errors i have to ask okay 400
billion or so
after adjusting for inflation how
in holy hell do you spend or blow that
much money
what did they do
a lot of it was homes i mean the build
mower which is still around you can go
visit it it's a hundred and forty
thousand square feet
and that's one of like ten homes that
william vanderbilt had it's absurd
that's like chelsea pier that's
ridiculous craziest thing here's what's
crazy about it too this just shows how
dumb their lives were so bill moore is
140 000 square feet george william
vanderbilt when he was william george no
george washington vanderbilt was his
name he hardly ever visited it it was he
it was the biggest house in the world i
think it still is and he hardly ever
went there he spent most of his time
like in his apartment in manhattan so
even when they built these ridiculous
mansions it was just for like a pissing
contest of these cousins and of these
siblings of who can spend the most money
and it really did not give them it was
just like a social race that they could
not win because
when when you have these heirs whether
it was the vanderbilts of the
rockefellers or the carnegie's that
whole the whole gilded age airs
all of their goal was to one-up each
other and they basically had unlimited
money so in that situation you're never
going to win that game and they just
kept going and going and going the game
where everyone loses everyone loses and
so they spend a lot of it on homes they
spend like and all these homes would
have a staff of you know 300 people
working at the home that they never went
to so it was it was just like that
here's what's really interesting too
the first vanderbilt air that i think
has actually lived a pretty cool life
and seems pretty happy do you know who
it is i do not
anderson cooper
no [ __ ] wow anderson cooper's his mother
is gloria vanderbilt gloria vanderbilt's
father was reggie vanderbilt who was the
last vanderbilt to have significant
money reggie vanderbilt inherited a ton
of money blew every cent of it his
daughter gloria
went on to have a child named anderson
cooper who went on to of course do like
build his own life with his own talents
not with his family's money and seems
like he's a pretty happy guy everyone
else in the book before him
seems miserable including his mother
gloria so that's i think that's pretty
telling that anderson cooper is like the
first vanderbilt who did not have money
and he seems like he's the happiest one
good for anderson wow i had no idea i
had absolutely no idea
i'm going to ask you some journalism and
book questions favorite
biographies you have recommended most to
other people or given the most to other
people uh biographies or just
recommended or gifted doesn't have to be
recommended the most okay well here's
it's not necessarily a biography but
it's a diary there is a lawyer named
benjamin roth who in the 1930s kept a
very detailed diary during the great
depression and every day it was just his
personal diary but he just wrote about
what was going on in his town he's from
youngstown ohio and he just wrote about
like what his neighbors were going
through how many businesses were going
bankrupt what that did to per people's
personalities and his son published it
in 2010 it's called a great depression a
diary and i think it was
it was unintentionally the best
economics book ever written wow
for sure it explains what went on during
the great depression in a way that no
one else has because there's no
hindsight bias in it every other book on
the depression is hindsight bias we know
how the story ends and that colors our
view of what happened but benjamin roth
was writing in real time every single
morning he woke up and he wrote a
thousand words and what was going on in
the economy and it's so fascinating to
read and one of the things that sticks
out to me that's so interesting is that
the half of the book if you change the
date from 1932 to 2008 it fits right in
like the the whole the psychology of
what happened back then of how people
were thinking how people thought about
risk what they thought about government
policy completely
repeated itself in 2008 and benjamin
roth actually talks about in 1932 he's
like oh what's going on today was
exactly what happened in 1878 it's like
all these things repeat themselves so
commonly and so frequently but it's
that's that's one that is not a very
well known book but i've read it i've
read it several times and i just think
it's fascinating a great depression i
know you're also a fan of uh you call
him your favorite historian
in the book frederick lewis allen
yep spanish career depicting the life of
the average median american i know
you've spoken about this before people
could definitely listen to your
conversation with shane parish for more
on this but
some of those books are
the big change since yesterday what is
the third the big change since yesterday
and only yesterday only yesterday
and
i suppose there's maybe a bit of
hindsign bias but it's it's
describing a period that he lived
through and therefore
i suppose is is just more
how would how would you summarize why
you find his work interesting
you hinted at this earlier but most
history books 99 of them are about the
big figures the presidents the generals
the the hitlers the stalins the fdrs
that's most of history virgin ghoulis
allen was just interested in how the
average ordinary american lived their
life and and he wasn't writing about any
specific events he just wanted to write
about like what was life like how did
life change
during this period from 1900 to 1950 his
crowning book is called the big change
it's just how american life evolved from
1900 to 1950 and the evolution was
enormous because 1900 was horse and
buggy and 1950 was like rockets and
atomic bombs like the amount of progress
that took place during that period is
way more than what we've dealt with over
the last 50 years and he just wrote
about what life was like for people who
lived through that ordinary people one
of the things that sticks out from that
too that comes up again and again
is just the extent that no one saw what
was coming
no one saw it coming what actually
happened no one saw that coming and even
if you look at like the dawning of these
big events like world war ii and the
great depression nobody saw them coming
it seems so obvious to you and i today
if you research what happened during the
1920s and what happened in 1929 like the
like the glorious roaring 20s in the
stock market bubble it's easy to be like
of course it all ended in calamity but
people were not saying that at the time
and the few people who did say hey this
was probably dangerous were completely
pushed aside same with the period right
before world war ii and the aftermath of
world war ii and the technologies that
came out of the cold war like again and
again
the repeating theme among the story is
that people didn't see it coming and
that just gives the reader so much
humility when you're looking at today
that you and i and everyone else and the
smartest people that we know have no
clue what's going to happen over the
next 10 years that's always been true
and i think it always will be true
one of the
sections
in the book that i really enjoyed
i mean maybe enjoy it isn't the right
word
you'll see why in a second but
found illuminating and worth
contemplating and
you'll have to help me with the
specifics here but it was
looking at
i want to say in brief how
misleading or incomplete averages can be
right so
you might look at something that says
at some statistic like from
i'm making this up from 1950 to 2000 the
s p 500 averaged whatever it happened
average seven percent per year i have no
idea what the actual number is
and that but then you you you go further
to explore how
lumpy and volatile that actually is
right it's not this nice clean
incline like
you know a ramp for wheelchairs or
something
and you list off all of the calamities
and disasters that took place over that
period of time and that the sort of
psychological experience
of
living through the years that ultimately
result in that average is very different
than what most people would expect so
feel free to
to correct or elaborate on that in any
way that makes sense but
my my meta question is
related to how terrible people are at
actually buying and holding right they
tend to panic and sell so
even with the knowledge that all this
[ __ ] is going to happen that the the one
guarantee is there's going to be a bunch
of unmitigated catastrophe that is
totally unexpected
how can you increase the likelihood that
you will
not respond
in moments of panic by doing
what
cripples you financially
so two parts of this one is that even if
you look at the periods that in
hindsight we think were the greatest
that existed which for most americans is
the 1950s and the 1990s that's what we
remember is like the golden age of
prosperity and happiness and peace even
if you look at those periods like in the
1950s people were high like do like kids
were doing nuclear bomb drills under
their desks and there was a lot of
pessimism and negativity even if we know
in hindsight it was great at the time by
and large they did not know that maybe
it was like it was good economically but
there was a lot to be worried about in
the 1950s same in the 1990s which we
like today it's like oh the booming
1990s the bull market but even like
people forget in 1994 there was a big
like interest rate calamity where a
bunch of bond like interest rates rose
and the stock market crashed and then in
1998 a big hedge fund
went out of business and almost took the
whole global economy down with it like
there was a lot to worry about during
these periods so how do you protect
yourself from that how do you actually
become buy and hold i think there's one
thing to do here there's a great there's
there's a friend of mine named carl
richards who's a financial advisor and
he has a quote where he says risk is
what is left over when you think you've
thought of everything i think that's
that like that's the definition of risk
is whenever we're done planning and
forecasting everything that's left over
that we haven't thought about that's
what risk actually is and the takeaway
from that the actual practical takeaway
is that if you are only planning for
risks that you can think about and you
can envision and you can imagine then 10
times out of 10 you're going to miss the
biggest risk
that actually hits you the biggest risk
is always something that nobody sees
coming including something like covet
where it's you know it's it's actually
not fair to say no one saw it coming but
by and large it's like in financial
circles not a single investor in 2019
and their economic outlook had a viral
pandemic as something they were worried
about not a single one or 911 or lehman
brothers going bankrupt like all the big
events that actually mattered it's
pretty much true to say no one saw them
coming i think that's generally true and
therefore the takeaway is
you have to have a level of savings
in your asset allocation that doesn't
make sense you have to have a level of
conservatism that seems like it's a
little bit too much that's that's the
only time that you know that you are
prepared for risks that you cannot
envision and if you are only prepared
for what you can imagine again you're
going to miss the biggest risk every
single time whenever people look at my
asset allocation if i share that with
them
it looks a little bit too conservative
and they say god you you could be taking
a little bit more risk and they're right
like i probably could but i want to be
prepared for the risks that i can't
imagine
or the risk that like is possible but
like i don't want to even think about
it's too painful to think about that's
the only time that you can be prepared
for the surprises in life and i i think
most people not all investors but the
majority investors
are not conservative enough and i know
like whenever i say that they kind of
shake their head like come on like why
are you why don't you want to take risk
and once a decade you learn why
once a day whether it's covid or 911 or
2008 once per decade you're like okay i
get it now i didn't see this coming it
was a calamity and i either like ground
myself into the floor and like i got
wiped out or i had a little bit of extra
savings that got me through so that's
that's how i think about you know how
how to stay in the game
in a long-term history where history is
a constant chain of surprises that's the
only way to do it yeah let me read up
one of my 17 million kindle highlights
thank you to your publisher for not
throttling the number of highlights that
i could actually
read after the fact that is extremely
annoying
when that happens so thank you publisher
who ended up publishing the book it's a
group in london called harriman house
and uh so we
we may or may not get a chance to dig
into this but
one of the bullets i have here is every
major publisher rejected the book that
seems just stupid especially based on
the
just based on the fact that my
understanding is it began as a
popular blog post it seems like
the most
obvious indicator of interest imaginable
but what do i know about publishing let
me we may we may come back to that but
let's let me just read something here
that i ended up highlighting so for
people who are wondering about my
process
i
highlight on the kindle in this
particular book i actually read in a way
i had not read any book before and that
was
i bought it on kindle that prompted me
to buy the audible version
and then i listened to the audible
inside the kindle app so that i could
while going for say a hike with my dog
be listening listening listening hit a
point where i would want to make a
highlight stop
and
it would be tracking simultaneously in
the kindle and i could then make my
highlight and then continue hiking and
listening so i i digested the book very
very quickly
here's a section that i then ended up
bolding because i take those highlights
which you can access on desktop
through your amazon account and i drop
them into a google document and then i
will go through them a second time and
i'll bold the section that i want to pay
particular attention to
and my friends some friends and i will
share our kindle highlights from
different books
that we have read so that we can
determine if we want to
end up reading the entire book so here's
a section and it's from a much larger
context of course but i think it kind of
makes the point
say cash earns one percent stocks earn
or return 10 a year that nine percent
gap will not you every day but if that
cash prevents you from having to sell
your stocks during a bear market the
actual return you earned on that cash is
not one percent here it could be many
multiples of that dot dot
and this leads me and i am going to come
back to the journalism question i
haven't forgotten that but since we're
on a bit of a thread here
i will say you know i ended up with a
tremendous cash reserve
in part because i got my nuts kicked
into my throat in
2007 2008
it just
both self-inflicted wounds in the case
of selling amazon and then in the
housing market
and i was very conservative after that
point or i should say i took
a barbell approach of sorts right so
nasim
talib talks about this but i was in the
bay area i felt like i had an
informational advantage if i wanted to
really commit time to trying to become
well versed and well networked within
technology so i decided to begin angel
investing that was the highly highly
speculative potentially high return
investing side of things and then the
rest was basically in cash i mean the
equivalent of being in a mattress i mean
i didn't even have the guts
to put it into an index
and i missed some tremendous tremendous
growth as a result of that it didn't
bother me though
at the time at least i was still
sleeping pretty well i was enjoying
learning what i was learning in tech
and then in
january i began tracking kova this is of
2020 and i was able to deploy a
ton of my cash reserves
basically end of march beginning of
april
so it did well
but
one could very
i think convincingly argue that i would
have made more money just by having it
play in the market for a longer period
of time
but i think that would have made it hard
for me to sleep at night having just had
my face ripped off i know i'm mixing a
lot of metaphors face balls you get it
but it was unpleasant this is the point
i'm trying to make
and i
i'm going to bring this back to
how you think about
success in investing and i hate that
word so i'll i'll i'll parse it out a
little bit but i want to read something
from a blog post that you wrote or an
article i'm not sure which you prefer
this is on the collaborative fund
website internal versus external
benchmarks
and let me just read these two
paragraphs
all right the most important point may
be this internal benchmarks are only
possible when you have some degree of
independence the only way to
consistently do what you want when you
want with whom you want for as long as
you want is to detach from other
people's benchmarks and judge everything
simply by whether you're happy and
fulfilled okay i want to bold that in
your mind judge everything simply by
whether you're happy and fulfilled which
varies person to person this next
paragraph i circled because i just
thought it was
really worth reading over and over again
i recently had dinner with a financial
advisor who had a client that gets angry
when hearing about portfolio returns or
benchmarks none of that matters to the
client all he cares about is whether he
has enough money to keep traveling with
his wife that's his sole benchmark quote
everyone else can stress out about
outperforming each other he says quote i
just like europe end quote maybe he's
got it all figured out so i just love
that because it's like an it is a
it is it's highly subjective meaning
it's personal but it's also very
objective it's an absolute measure
and it's an it's it's an example of you
know unless he gets a lot of lifestyle
bloat and wants to have a yacht in the
mediterranean or something
it is a goal post that won't move
all right so you talk about the
importance of the goal posts not moving
in my experience with people who have
gone from
very very moderate circumstances
not having much money growing up to
being very very successful
offhand i'm sure there are some examples
but 99 of the people who come to mind
who are smart i think good people who
are very much students of life the goal
posts have always moved
and so i want to know what you've seen
work or not work in that
specific domain and
how you think about it for yourself
i think it's it's the single most
important topic
in money in investing in finance and
it's the hardest thing to actually make
work
those are both true statements it's the
same for me i can write about this and
say what people should do but it's the
same for my wife and i like we struggle
with this as much as anyone else about
getting the goalposts to stop moving i
think if there is one thing
that has helped
me and i would say helped not fix just
like i helped a little bit around the
edges it's something that we talked
about earlier which is that just the
idea the observation that no one is
thinking about you as much as you are
and therefore so much of people's
willingness and their desire to spend
more it's just a social signal to show
people how much money you have whether
that's the bigger house the nicer car
like whatever it is like you just want
to show other people and once you
realize that people aren't thinking
about you that much they don't care
about you that much they're thinking
about themselves and how much people
care about them
once you realize that then you're like
okay i i can see what the game is it's a
game that i can't win so i'm not even
gonna try to play it i'm just gonna i
just wanna focus on the internal of like
what's going to make me happy what do i
want what's actually going to give me
pleasure and let's just do that and i
don't want to think about anyone else so
much of this is just selfish what's the
happy and whatever the other thing i
bolded which i promptly forgot
but what are those things for you i want
to wake up every morning and hang out
with my kids and i want them to be happy
and i want to do it on my own schedule
if it's a wednesday morning and i don't
want to work then i'm going to sit on
the couch all day and watch netflix and
if it's a sunday and i got a good idea
i'm going to spend all day working it's
all my own schedule on my own time
whatever i want to do it's that
independence and autonomy can you not do
that right now
yeah i can there was a point when i
couldn't and that's why i feel like i'm
i'm pretty happy and i feel like i've
done a decent job of doing that now i do
have as a lot of people would a tendency
to be like oh what if i got that porsche
what if we got the bigger house what if
we did this what if we did that
and it's fun to think that because i
love nice cars i love nice i love all of
that it's just so easy to realize
there's a great quote that i love that's
the grass is always greener on the side
that's fertilized with [ __ ] i think
that's that's really what it is that's
the accurate phrasing of that of that
well-known quote and
i think that's really what it is like
the idea that all that nicer stuff is
gonna make you necessarily happier i
think is just so easy to disprove
especially once you've experienced a
little bit of it yourself and that
actually what is gonna make people happy
is that independence and autonomy that
once i remind myself of that i'm like
okay and then the game of earning more
just becomes
a a game it's less about like oh if i
have more money i'm going to be happier
no if my net worth is 10x what it is
today i'm not going to be any happier
that was not true at one point in my
life but i think it's true today it's
probably true for you right now it's
true for a lot of people listening and
therefore you can admit that a game is
fun and the game is fun to play but just
admit that it's a game and it's actually
not going to make you happier yeah
i think i may have a solution for you i
think that
all of that experience as a valet could
come back to serve you if you took like
a saturday shift as a valet and took a
few porsches for a joy ride
i think you could scratch that itch
without the expense uh or the
guilt and karma associated with buying
one you can also buy one certainly but
see actually i don't think i've ever
talked about this before but i actually
do scratch that itch when i rent a car
when i'm traveling i rent a car i always
get the extreme upgrade the highest
upgrade that they have a lot of times
enterprise will have a porsche or
something sitting around and whatever
the price is i'm doing that that's how i
scratch the itch that i have without
actually buying it that's a great way to
do it you can rent a porsche from
enterprise for like 300 bucks a day it's
not cheap it's not it's not 60 bucks a
day but it's a lot different than buying
the damn thing
so let's talk a little bit more about
scratching the edge because
the question that i asked a while back
was how can people
fortify themselves against their lesser
instincts when [ __ ] goes sideways
because it's always going to go sideways
right so if they know i need to be in
this for the long haul let's just call a
long haul at least 20 30 years but in
the meantime a lot of things are going
to happen
i remember i think this was in the book
maybe maybe this isn't a conversation
that i heard of yours where
you know if someone has the
impulsive the the unbridled passion and
impulse to trade or pick stocks that's
fine as long as you
kind of cordon off a small amount of
your money as kind of play money in the
same way that you might scratch the itch
by renting the porsche at enterprise
right right so that would be one way
theoretically again maybe easier on
paper than it is in practice
to
handle some of the damage control
could you speak to other ways that
people can kind of philosophically
psychologically prepare themselves
for a long haul that is going to be very
bumpy and
you know one of the discussions in the
book was
and i'm going to get the wording off
here but related to
accepting the prices you will have to
pay up front with a commitment to such a
strategy right yeah and the the fees
that are involved
could you speak to that
yeah and the way that i phrased it in
the book was understanding the
difference between a fee and a fine
which seems like they're really similar
but there's a very important difference
which is a fine means you did something
wrong
like shame on you here's your speeding
ticket don't do it ever again you're in
trouble and a fee is just a price of
admission that you paid to get something
better on the other side like you go to
disneyland you pay the fee and then you
get to enjoy the theme park it's it's
you didn't do anything wrong it's just
that's the fee i think if you view if
you if you could situate your life to
where you view a lot of the ups and
downs not all of it but a lot of the
volatility in investing a lot of the
volatility in your career as a fee
instead of a fine then it just becomes a
little bit more palatable and when the
market falls 30 it's not that you enjoy
it you don't think it's fun but you're
like okay i understand this is the fee
that i have to be willing to pay in
order to do well over a long period of
time most investors don't do that when
their portfolio falls 30 percent they
say i [ __ ] up i did something wrong i
clearly made a mistake and how can i
make sure this never happens again and
that's that's the wrong way to think
about it and i i think if you if you
view it as a fee instead of a fine it's
just it's much more enjoyable it's much
more realistic to deal with now there i
i said earlier that there are some areas
in life where it's like that if you're
talking about
a death in the family a divorce there's
things that it's like no that's not
that's just that's that's just a
straight negative like no silver lining
to some of these things in life so i
want to be careful at parsing that but
particularly in investing the huge
majority of the pain that people go
through and put themselves through is
just the fee for earning superior
returns over time
and if you're not willing to pay that
then you're you're probably not going to
get the reward on the other side that's
why you can see so many people who at
the first
at their first experience with being
uncomfortable in investing with a loss
they view it as a screwed up and then
they want out they want to move on to
something else
and of course they're not they're not
going to get the rewards over time
nothing in life is going to give you
those rewards for free there's a cost to
everything and just identifying what the
cost is and realizing that the cost is
not on a price tag you're going to pay
for it with stress and anxiety and
dopamine and cortisol like that's how
you pay for these things is i think
that's the only way to deal with those
those big ups and downs
journalistic question twitter doesn't
exist parallel universe called much more
peace of mind
[Laughter]
less doom scrolling and hatred and
neighborhoods online where people throw
potted plants in your head as you walk
down the sidewalk so parallel universe
twitter doesn't exist
and
the way you consume your
news is the following you're allowed to
read the cover of a handful of
newspapers that's it can't flip to any
interior pages but you can kind of scan
a handful of newspapers okay that's not
the part i want to
i want to ask about but that's that's
part one part two
is you get to choose and let's limit it
for now to
finance investing
or business okay broadly speaking you
get to choose a handful of
journalists writers and you just you
basically have an rss feed to their
articles and you get those automatically
but that's it
on those subjects
that's how you get your information who
are some of the people you would choose
okay one would be and i'll try to give
some names that are not that well known
they're not under the radar but they're
not
the biggest names one is a guy named
nick majuli m-i-j-j-i-l-u-i
i i'm probably butchering that but he's
he's on twitter he writes a blog called
of dollars in data
and i think he's a young guy he's maybe
in his early 30s and he's one of the
smartest insightful and good writers
that i've come across in years he was
one i i'm good friends with him now and
i tell him the story that the first time
that i read his blog maybe 10 years ago
i read one paragraph and after one
paragraph i stopped and i was like this
guy's got it it's that's all you needed
to read to be like i this guy is smart
and he can write and he's got it it was
so clear early on he's one of them josh
brown who i mentioned earlier who is a
ceo of rituals wealth management he's
he's well known he's on tv all the time
he is one person that i think is as
funny as he is smart and to put those
two together in one package is really
rare and that humor is important for
understanding the context of these it's
so much of it is just like he
understands the human side of investing
better than almost anyone i mentioned
derek thompson earlier of the atlantic
he's just he's one of the smartest
humans that i know and he's also maybe
like 32 years old something like that
he's definitely on that list
jason zweig who we mentioned earlier is
probably the the greatest financial
journalist of modern times i don't think
that's an exaggeration carl richards who
i mentioned earlier too used to write
from the new york times he doesn't
anymore but he has a way of taking
really complicated thoughts and making
them just so easy to understand
in a way that you thought you understood
it before but once you read carl's work
you're like okay now now it really makes
sense he would definitely be on the list
what is carl's beat or what is he right
about he was a financial advisor and
then he wrote for the new york times for
a long time basically on behavioral
finance his book is called the behavior
gap and so so he so he wrote about
behavior finance for a long time and now
he's just on his personal blog his
personal newsletters he's definitely on
that there's a financial advisor named
blair dukane who i think is incredibly
smart and a great writer i wish he wrote
more but whenever she does it's just
always very well put together and very
thoughtful if if you gave me more time i
could probably list 10 more but off the
top my head that that's that's the mount
rushmore in my mind
are there you said i'll leave off some
of the bigger names are there any of the
bigger names you would care to mention
i think i i mentioned earlier james
clear ryan holliday mark manson you tim
i don't want to blow too much smoke but
i'll just leave i'll just drop that
there and then move on uh you know i i
think i think those people like that
that have a lot of success and a lot of
followers have earned it like content is
a meritocracy and for people who have
sold a zillion books and have a million
followers and get this i think by and
large they've earned it and so a lot of
those people who are big names and
almost cliche to mention i think are
very insightful people james clear and
ryan holiday are two
that
that that really stick out as just like
really thoughtful almost philosophers in
a way that can be off-putting to some
people but i think they are just so
smart and a funny story about this in
2018 some friends of mine rented a house
in omaha for the berkshire hathaway
shareholder meeting and a guy came over
who i had never met before
and i said hey who are you and he said
oh hi i'm james clear and i said what do
you do and he said i'm i'm an author i'm
writing a book right now i said what's
it called he said that's called atomic
habits
and i didn't say this but at the time i
was like that sounds like a dumb name i
don't know that's that's not of course i
didn't say that to him but in my head
i'm like atomic habits that sounds
cheesy
and but he explained it he was a really
nice guy i like talking to him but for
those who don't know i think atomic
habits has now sold five or six million
copies it's probably the best-selling
book of the last five years yeah
blockbuster
yeah ryan also i'll just speak to ryan
since i know ryan quite well and i've
known him for a very long time he really
walks the walk and makes every effort to
walk the walk so i have tremendous
respect
for ryan also because there's such
congruency at the very least incredible
effort put into congruency between
the words and deeds if that makes sense
because uh that is not always the case
you know who comes to mind for me also
is
matt levine i have to guess slovene i
don't know if it's levine but matt
levine of bloomberg i have no idea how
he manages to put out the volume
with the density of insight and humor
that he does he has some hilarious
hilarious stuff it's so good and he
writes every day he puts out a letter
five days a week and they're long posts
yeah and every one of them is great
there's almost never a dud he actually
he gave an interview last week where he
talks about his process and he said his
process is like he wakes up at 6 a.m and
panics until there's something written
which i think that that's a great a
great thing to admit that like writing
is hard it's not even for the people
that make it look easy it's it's almost
always like a daily panic attack of like
oh [ __ ] what am i going to do now what
am i going to write about now the other
observation i make about all these
people matt levine james clear ryan
holiday all those people is that
their skill is very universal and their
observations could be applied to other
fields like if ryan holiday wanted to
become like a writer of astronomy or
like soccer games or like a medical
writer he would be one of the best
medical writers if james clear wanted to
write about like early childhood
education he would be the best childhood
education writer they're just great
observers of how the world works and
great communicators of putting those
observations onto paper
what's your hall of fame personal hall
of fame just for you
favorite books on investing finance
behavioral finance any of that kind of
stuff decision making
one that's not that well known but i i
wish was and it's it's not a behavioral
finance book per se but it's a
behavioral book is a book by a guy named
dan gardner who wrote a book called the
science of fear
the title's basically self-explanatory
and it's not a deep science book i would
say it's more of a pop science book but
i don't mean that in a derogatory way
it's very digestible you can understand
it but that book really changed how i
think about fear and just observing fear
in in a pretty profound way i've read
that several times what else i mean
obviously the word from jason's wife so
let's bookmark jason's wife how did it
change how you think about or relate to
fear
i think what that book really showed me
and and put into words in a way that
really stuck with me is the difference
between your slow
thoughtful process of thinking about
future risks and the oh [ __ ] like heat
of the moment how am i actually going to
react
in in the book it's framed as head
versus gut
years later daniel kahneman the great
psychologist framed it as system one
system two i think that's really
important and particularly in investing
where like we've talked about in this
podcast it's so easy to sit back in your
armchair and be like oh if the market
fell 20 i would do x i and z and then
when it actually happens you don't you
think something totally different it's a
very different experience the difference
between what you think and what you
actually do can be 10 miles apart and
that book really explains that quite
well
now how does that affect your
you said you've read it several times
how does that affect your
planning
or behavior
i don't fool myself hey i think a big
part of me of just like taking this off
the table for me that relieves a lot of
pressure is like i have no desire to
become the world's greatest investor and
i i respect people who do
but i'm not one of that so when i you
know if i can just compound my money
passively for 50 years i'm gonna achieve
every goal that i have and then some so
for me the idea of like well how can i
take the greatest advantage over the
next market crash how can i maximize
more portfolio i'm just not playing that
game
and once i'd like become more
introspective about my own personality
about what i want and how i react how i
think how i interpret stress how prone i
am to stress that kind of thing it's
like once once you become more
introspective about yourself i just took
that pressure off my shoulders in a way
that was very relieving
i would like
some
writing advice
i used to turn this into uh even more
self-indulgent conversation for myself
self-gratifying maybe
what made me think of this was actually
flashing back on kovid because i had
committed to getting back on the blog
and writing regularly right before kovid
hit and i had
i had built up a bit of momentum had hit
publish a handful of times
and then covet hit and i was like okay
that's
not a priority at the moment right i
want to figure out
how to keep my extended family as safe
as possible and martial resources and
plan for contingencies
and have not gotten back on the saddle
since even though i've drafted a few
things here and there haven't hit
publish i would like to get back into
some regular cadence of writing and i'm
wondering if you have any
advice or would care to
describe your writing process if you
think it might be helpful
i don't know if i really have a writing
process other than
i really don't try to schedule it or say
okay like monday is writing day and i'm
gonna sit down and do it i know a lot of
great writers who would come on this
show and say that that's the way to do
it that your routine is so important for
better or worse it's never been like
that for me i just kind of take as a
leap of faith that
maybe twice or three times a month i'll
come up with an insight where i'm like
oh that would be pretty cool and here's
a story that i could tell but i don't
try to force it at all every good idea
that i've come up with has come when i'm
not trying to force it at all it's like
in the shower or going for a walk or
going for a run that you just all of a
sudden you're like oh i got it here's
the idea and so the process for me is no
process it's just like wander aimlessly
around life and then it'll eventually
come to you the actual writing for me
i would say too i go for a lot of walks
i walk several times a day just around
my neighborhood and 90 of the quote
unquote writing takes place there i i
don't think that well when i'm sitting
at my computer in front of a google doc
typing but when i get up and move around
and go for a walk then i'm like oh
here's how i can write that paragraph
here's how i can do it like oh actually
that sentence here's a better way to
phrase it all that takes place when i'm
walking never when i'm sitting and so
for me whenever
i uh i feel like an article is not going
well or like i'm stuck a little bit it's
like okay let's go for a walk and then
most of the time i'll figure it out
there
the other thing that i've i've come to
realize about myself is that
the majority of the time that you have
writer's block it's not that you have
writer's block it's that your idea sucks
and that's why you can't figure out a
way to write it like good ideas are very
easy to write and bad ideas are hard
like that's that's pretty easy so a lot
of a lot of writers when they they get
writer's block they're like oh how can i
muscle through this and figure it out
and i think nine times out of ten you're
like no let's take a step back and maybe
it's hard to put this into words because
the idea that you're trying to get
across is wrong and that's why it's hard
so i've tried to do that with myself of
just quitting pretty easily even if i'm
halfway through an article and i'm like
oh i can't figure out how to phrase this
it's like well maybe that's because my
idea is wrong and i should just move on
to something else how do you distinguish
between
a block that is due to an impotent idea
versus
uh performance anxiety slash pressure
that is preventing you from moving
forward does that make sense like if
your standards for yourself were too
high the idea may be good but you're
just expecting tolstoy to roll out and
then you're like this isn't tolstoy [ __ ]
and then you can't write i i think that
i end up there a fair amount because i'm
clearly not tolstoy
it's definitely the case if you are
writing for a big publication and you
have a deadline like your deadline is
like 3 p.m on friday you need to turn
your article in then you you have to do
it if you're if you are away from those
handcuffs and you can just kind of
publish whenever you want
that that to me is the best setup for a
writer
because here's like the truth is even if
you are one of the big name writers if
you miss a week no one's going to hold
it against you no one's going to care
what they want is good content and if
you miss if it takes you an extra week
to come up with the next good idea just
do that so i publish on random days
sometimes i publish once a week
sometimes it's twice a month it's just
whenever i come up with something that i
think is is worth writing about that
that i do so freeing yourself from that
that timeline if you can is is the only
way to do that for me and i i think i
think if there's one thing i've gotten a
little bit better at over the last 15
years of doing this
it's having a little bit better sense
before i sit down and write whether it's
going to work or not i think in the past
like a lot of times i would work on
something for five hours before i
realized like no this isn't working now
i feel like within 10 minutes of writing
i'd be like nope nope this is not going
anywhere good let's just quit this and
move on to the next idea and that's fine
there's also a lot of
times where you write half an article
that doesn't work out but there's some
story in that in that scrap of an
article that's gonna work a year from
now or six months from now so saving all
those scraps is really helpful and maybe
you told a great story this article that
didn't work out and so you just leave
that in your drafts but then a year from
now you're like oh i got this story
where do you save that
i have a google doc called scrapped bits
and that's where it is it's it's like
it's like 50 000 words it's over 10
years of just the paragraphs that i cut
from articles and i get a lot of
material in future articles from that
scrap bits that didn't work in the past
could you give an example of a recent
story or article
and like where the idea occurred to you
and then what the next steps were right
after that one article that i wrote
fairly recently is called how this all
happened
which is a very
a short history of how the u.s economy
evolved
from the end of world war ii through
today and i don't want to write a
complete history that's too ambitious
but just what are the connecting dots
from how we got from here or from the
end of world war ii to today like how
like what's the what's the narrative of
how this all happened i just wanted to
connect the dots between all those and
it started actually years ago when i
said like how can i write the history of
the us economy basically in tweets like
what is the shortest that i can do this
and just write a couple sentences of
like okay after world war ii this
happened and then that happened and the
whole article is like 10 sentences i
wanted to like challenge myself to
summarize it that quickly and so that
was i don't know eight years ago that i
wrote that piece then i realized hey
that was actually like a cool format but
there's obviously a lot to expand on
there so rather than writing the history
of the us economy in single sentences
like what if i just put it together in
each block each chapter is like 300
words which is a length in which like
you can go into a little bit of detail
but it's it's quick you can breeze
through it so this putting that together
in that in that format was like a
challenge but i was pretty happy with
how it turned out
let's grab another one just because i
think that that format wise is
maybe a typical maybe not but what would
be another example
of kind of an an a to z single piece
that
you could tell the story of like the
genesis story of like all right the idea
you don't have to have the exact time
and place but like when you have this
idea what happens next like are do you
start drafting it in your mind as you're
walking are you like oh [ __ ] here comes
the muse let me get back to my computer
so i can start brain vomiting
everything that comes to mind down
or something else the majority of the
time that i start writing an article i
have no idea where it's going to go and
no idea how it's going to end and the
actual act of writing is kind of what
gets the brain moving and you write one
sentence and then you're like oh that
reminds me of this other thing and then
you write a paragraph and you go oh that
reminds me of this thing i read five
years ago to pull it in and so it's
really i think that's the art of writing
is you don't have any idea where it's
going to go it's true for articles is
true for entire books when i started
writing my book i didn't really know
what the format was going to be how long
i didn't know what the chapters were
going to be it was just let's start
putting this together and see where it
goes i think a lot of writers do
themselves a disservice
by writing as you're taught in school
which is like have your outline have it
all outlined before you start writing
it's like no that takes away the
creativity and the art of like exploring
as you go that's been really interesting
for me so it often starts with just one
little tiny nugget of like oh that's
really interesting and i go from there
i'll give you one example that i got
from your show you had steven pressfield
on your show fairly recently and he was
talking about a time when he lived in a
mental institution he was not he was not
a patient himself but he lived there and
he starts talking to all these people
and he made this comment that a lot of
the common denominators of these people
who lived in a menstrual institution was
they were not they were not crazy they
just could not handle or put up with the
[ __ ] of life they couldn't they they
just couldn't deal with it and that that
was kind of why they ended up in the
mental institution and he said all these
people were the smartest most creative
people who he had ever met but they
couldn't put up they had no tolerance
for the [ __ ] of the real world and
that to me just like brought this idea
that there's actually an optimal amount
of [ __ ] to deal with in life
if your tolerance for [ __ ] is zero
you're not gonna make it at all in life
yeah the lesson i took from that was
maybe i should live in a mental
institution please continue
but that's i listened to that and it was
like oh see these people could not
function in the real world because they
had no tolerance for [ __ ] like the
second step from that is there is an
optimal amount of [ __ ] to put up
with in life and that was where this
article the optimal amount of hassle
came from and i i i remember like i was
on a flight many years ago and there was
this guy in pinstripe suits who let
everyone know that he was a ceo of some
company and the flight was like two
hours delayed and he completely lost his
mind he was dropping f-bombs to the gate
agents and just like completely making
an ass of himself because the flight was
delayed and i remember thinking like how
could you make it this far in life and
have no tolerance for petty annoyance
like a delayed flight and i just think
like there's a big skill in life in
terms of just being able to deal with
some level of [ __ ] and a lot of
people don't have that there's another
great quote that i love from fdr who of
course was paralyzed and and in a
wheelchair and he said when you're in a
wheelchair and you want milk but they
bring you orange juice instead you learn
to say that's all right and just drink
it and i think that just having the
ability to put up with that kind of
stuff is i think really important and
often lost in this age where we want
perfection we want everything to be
perfect and it never is
so just to track the trajectory like
birth cycle of this
of this article you wrote the optimal
amount of hassle is that right yeah and
i actually remember i was going for a
run listening to your podcast with
steven pressfield i heard him talk about
the story of the people in the mental
institution could not put up with it i
stopped and i sent myself an email which
is how i take notes and i said like
optimal amount of hassle steven
pressfield and then i put like the time
stamp in your podcast that was and then
i kept running and then i came home and
then like i just had that nugget the
next day just that no idea where it was
going to go but let's start with that
and see where it takes me that was the
genesis of that article all right thank
you i just find that you know it's it's
like tomato tomato everyone has a
different approach to this there's no
consensus whatsoever because then there
are folks
i mean people are probably long time
listeners sick of hearing me mention
this name but like john mcphee and you
read draft number four and like he has
the structure
anatomically
decided to such a level of precision
that it is almost unbelievable but you
know before he gets going most of the
time right like he has everything it's
like a it's like a
like a nasa
space shuttle launch
there's nothing left to chance or very
little
i'm pretty sure ryan holiday is like
that as well he talks a lot about
routine is so important to his writing
and for me it hasn't and and my my
takeaway is not that
i'm right or he's right i just it is
different for everyone and maybe i would
be a better writer if i had more routine
but for better or worse i've just kind
of
slapped it together haphazardly over the
years so you you were a junior olympic
ski racer i want to bring this up
in part and we we may we may or may not
have time to get into this right now but
i really recommend people read the the
three sides of risk
which is a piece you wrote which i read
which is
i mean a a
an extremely heart-wrenching
and
poignant piece uh so thank you for
writing that
but you you were i mean skiing was
life for a a good stretch of your
childhood and adolescence and you were
very very serious
athlete in training yep i have a bullet
here
i'll let people see behind the curtain
here i i will often ask
guests if there are any
particular topics or questions they
think might be
interesting fun
productive fill in your adjective to
explore and one of the bullets that you
set was i have no formal high school
education yep could you please say more
about this
well i grew up as a competitive ski
racer as you mentioned in lake tahoe and
ski racing is one of the only sports
that it was pretty common for people in
my group in this competitive ski racing
group to view high school as a nuisance
that got in the way of our skiing and
the way that we got around that because
we were skiing six days a week
and so like the amount of like we just
didn't have we just viewed it as we
didn't have time to go to school and so
the way that we got around that was
there was an independent study program
that was designed for juvenile
delinquents who had been like expelled
from every other school that was kind of
like a homeschooling it was like a
guided homeschooling
system
where we didn't have to go to a high
school we had like they gave us some
work packets to fill out that we did and
then when i was 16 years old they sent a
diploma in the mail it's not a ged it's
a real high school diploma but i did
nothing for it like i don't i actually i
don't have any memory of actually doing
academic work during these years doing
it they had some work packets where it's
like can you spell your name and tie
your shoes is basically like how i
remember it was just like the most basic
bare bones stuff and then i got a
diploma for that so i really had no high
school education i spent my entire
teenage years just skiing that was the
sole focus and everyone else in my
cohort all of my friends around me did
the exact same thing so it felt normal
to me it wasn't until i was a little bit
older that i realized that like hey
everyone else went to four years of high
school and they actually learned
something that i didn't where did you
end up going to
college
i got my degree from usc okay but i kind
of slipped my way in there since i had
no high school education well i was
going to ask how the hell did you get
into usc
yeah so i had to start at because i
basically had an eighth grade education
up until that point so i started when i
was 19 or 20. so i was a little bit
older
than others to begin with and i started
at the local junior college in truckee
california where i lived and i started
to start at like the most remedial
math that exists it was it was basically
eighth grade math that i had to start
and i was 20 at the time and it was
really like okay like how to simplify
fractions it was really like starting at
that level so i was in junior college
for a year or two and then i transferred
to the university of nevada reno i was
living in lake tahoe at the time i went
to unr for a year and then i went to
another junior college in southern
california and then i transferred to usc
and i was there for three years and then
got my degree there so my whole college
experience was i don't know like seven
years or something because i had to
start at the very bottom
this might sound like a silly question
but
why did you go to college like why go
through that trajectory
versus taking a different path
i think there was a period when i didn't
think i was going to when i was you know
18 or 19 and i wanted to be a ski racer
now every ski racer at that level knows
the odds of you making the us ski team
and going on the olympics it's it's
0.0001 that you actually go there so
like i i knew that i was not going to
become the next lindsey vaughn but i
knew but i really enjoyed it i thought
oh man i'll probably go on to be a coach
that'll probably be what i'll do for the
rest of my life
and i think working as a valet at a nice
hotel in tahoe that was my first
experience to very wealthy people first
time i had seen very wealthy people
coming in in their ferraris and their
lamborghinis and the rolls-royces and it
was the first time in my life that i was
like oh like i want i want to be that
which is funny thinking now because that
like the guy in the rolls-royce is like
i i definitely don't want to be that guy
now but at the time i was like whatever
you're doing i want to do it i like like
whatever i got to do to get there this
guy is so cool i want to do it and most
of them were working in finance i
learned so i was like cool like i'm
going to wall street that's that's what
you did that's what i'll do now too
and so that was my first indication of
like so i think to answer your question
i did it because i wanted to become rich
which is that's not how i think now
that's it's it's funny to say that but i
think in my 19 year old mind that's why
i went to college
i want to dig into this question of
writing because how on earth do you
learn to write if you were not doing
coursework
to speak of during high school you got
to college but as you mentioned more
math focused once you got to econ then
writing focused
so why did your friend think you had a
snowball's chance in hell of of getting
a gig at motley fool or was there just
no downside so it didn't matter he was
like hey if
you throw a thousand monkeys into our
room and let them bang on typewriters
eventually they'll come up with
shakespeare i mean what was
what was the
sort of grist for the mill behind any
ability to write
i'll give you one little story about
where it all like the level of which i
was at and i was probably 21 at the time
when this happened but i was i wrote a
paragraph i forget what but a friend of
mine looked at it it was just like it
was just like a note that we wrote at
work
and he said he was a good friend of mine
and he was
a smart guy himself and he said hey
morgan do you know the difference
between then and then t-h-e-n and
t-h-a-n he said because you used it
wrong in this paragraph three times you
said then but you met then he said do
you know the difference and i said
no now that i think about it i don't i
could not explain to you when to use
each one and that was when i was 21
years old i just say that like the level
i was at was so basic i really had an
eighth grade education
90 of which i had forgotten at that
point and then so to go from that and
then try to become a professional writer
when i was an econ major that didn't
have any writing it was terrifying it
really was and the first year like i
said earlier was was bad it was i was
really self-conscious about what i was
writing and it needed heavy editing on
behalf of these like angel editors of
the molly fool that were walking me
through it but the answer to that
question was i didn't think i could do
it i had no self-confidence it's
incredible that they let me do it i i
would say if there was one like
point to this the first article that i
wrote for the motley fool i wrote a
draft and i sent it to a co-worker i was
at the private equity firm at the time i
sent it to the co-worker
and he said hey this is really good this
is actually really well written and i
was like really is that is that true and
when i go back and look at it now like
it's not that good but i think early on
i did have some aptitude of like putting
a little story together even if it was
it was pretty bad back then but i had
some little seed of like maybe i do have
some skill at trying to do this even if
it was really hard grinding through it
jeez what an adventure man
you know it's like if you you just think
about all the chance encounters and
you know random occurrences
the kind of blessings and disasters also
uh you want to hear about chance chance
encounters about where this all led to i
mentioned my friend who was a writer at
the motley fool
who who got me into this his name is
sham gatt he's he's still a great
investor great writer out there and i
came across
sham and i became friends because he
wrote a blog and in his blog post he had
a he had a personal blog and in a blog
post he had a typo an error that drove
me crazy and i emailed him he was a
complete stranger and i said hey you got
this error you need to fix it and he
wrote back and he said hey thanks i'll
correct it by the way i see from your
email address that you go to usc i'm
going to be at la next week do you want
to meet up for dinner
complete stranger who i just wrote a
nasty email to and i said great yeah
let's meet up and sham and i met and
during that dinner he said hey i don't
have a place to stay tonight do you have
do you know of any hotels around here
and i said do you want to sleep on my
couch and he said that would be great
thanks so this complete and utter
stranger who i was writing to to tell
him that he was wrong the next day he's
sleeping on my couch he and i became
good friends and that's how i got into
writing that's a he introduced me to the
motley fool so it was like if he didn't
have that typo in his blog post that i
was a jerk enough to write at to email
him and say this is wrong uh i i
wouldn't i wouldn't have had this career
that i've had it's like there's so many
little serendipitous accidents in life
that are like that
isn't that the truth so i want to
uh start to
bring us to a close you're being very
generous with your time but we're going
to come up on three hours shortly so let
me
let me bring us to
a recent piece that you wrote
very recent
and it's titled i have a few questions
and it's it's really
it's it's i don't i don't want to
minimize it by saying just but it is a
list of questions and it starts with
they're relevant to everyone and apply
to lots of things colon and then there
is a whole list
of questions and i would like to ask you
some of them i encourage people to check
this out we'll put it into the show
notes as well
but i want to throw a few of these at
you so one is
what do i think is true but is actually
just good marketing
and i'm wondering if anything comes to
mind that you suspect may fall into that
category
i try to keep them to myself uh and i
don't i don't write or tweet about this
but i have i have my political views and
i'm sure a lot of that is just
catch phrases and and talking points
that i have over the years been like ah
that i i
like that that makes sense to me that
i've run with that has been persuasive
to me and it's just someone came up with
something that's not really true but
like sounds really good there's also
probably some investing beliefs that i
have
that sound good that are very simple
maybe maybe it's around passive
investing maybe it's around you know my
admiration for warren buffet i don't
know what it is but that sounds really
good and it's easy to explain but it's
actually not how the world works so i i
think by definition i don't know the
answer to that question but i know that
there are things that i believe in my
heart that are just not true
yeah it's uh i remember somebody asked
me what are your blind spots and i was
like i'm not sure i can answer that
by definition by definition you can't
see them next one what looks
unsustainable but is actually a new
trend we haven't accepted yet
i think it's it's accepted by many now
but a lot in crypto probably falls in
that camp the thing about crypto that's
so interesting is that every new
technology going back for hundreds of
years
has started in with a dynamic that is
completely unsustainable and
very often times it then it then
collapses and like just entered but it
still stays around like was was the
internet in the late 1990s a bubble yes
and in the sense that the market fell 90
and 99 of the companies went out of
business but the internet was of course
a real thing it was that was not a fake
thing that was that was the wave of the
future and every new industry is exactly
like that like in the early 1900s there
were 2 000 car companies in the united
states and that whittled its way down to
three two of which one went bankrupt
eventually there's a big difference
between is something like uns like
growing at an unsustainable rate in
terms of like the market cap or whatnot
and is this technology a way for the
future i think there's probably a lot in
crypto that falls in that bucket
you i don't know if you wrote about this
or if i read it somewhere else but
there's an example you could tell me
i read
looking at
historic
gas prices it's hydrocarbons and
somebody had written some time ago that
as we look at the remaining stores of
of oil the price is going to get to be
so absurd that
you know we're going to run out of
supplies by this point in time and all
these disasters are going to be false i
think china uh it was looking at chinese
consumption of oil but
what
wasn't taken into account of course was
how
innovation and incentives would drive
new behaviors as
the price you know the the dollars per
barrel got higher and higher and higher
right
because all of a sudden things like
fracking or going to certain far-flung
locations to drill
or offshore drilling or whatever became
financially feasible as the prices got
more and more absurd and stratospheric
right yep
maybe that's not the most appetizing
example
using the word one other example is from
thomas malthus who of course like wrote
this essay many years ago
i don't know when that was 200 years ago
something that humans are all going to
starve to eventually like famine is the
future because population growth is
growing faster than we can generate new
food and therefore famine is the future
and his calculations were accurate but
what he didn't he didn't take into
consideration is that we would become
better at growing food and more
effective more efficient at growing food
there's a long history of that of like
the calculations can make sense but you
underestimate people's ability to adapt
and to come up with new ways new
technologies to create more
it's also easy to underestimate
self-regulating systems right i remember
reading
the lessons of history by will and ariel
durant and they talk about
what is it
famine war and pestilence right like
yeah you think you have too many humans
don't worry
they'll take them out yeah yeah case
study covid
which was sort of a warning flare more
than
anything else yeah looking at the
consequences that could have been all
right so let's look at
some of these other questions but which
i encourage encourage people to check
out it's it's uh it's a fun thought
exercise if nothing else what has been
true for decades it will stop working
but will drag along stubborn adherence
because because it has such a long track
record of success what comes to mind for
you
there's a lot within value investing
that falls in this camp value investing
will always work in terms of if you buy
an asset for less than it's worth you'll
probably do pretty well over time but
the actual formulas that you use to
determine value those have always
evolved and always changed and the
formulas that people use
whether it's like price to book value
the p e ratio whatever formula it is
that may have worked at one period of
time those always evolve that's always
been the case and it's i think it always
will be the case that there will be
people that will be stubbornly attached
to the metrics and the formulas and the
valuation techniques that that worked
perfectly in the previous era that are
now outdated and outmoded
i was chatting with someone you know
during during covet i thought a lot
about investing and spoke to a lot of
people about investing before making
some of my decisions and
it seems like value investing
took
some serious body shots beginning in
kind of i don't want to say across the
board because there are success stories
of course but 2013 2014 as
certain tech stocks and
impressive rates of growth of said tech
stocks began to really pull the indices
right does that make any sense yeah
where all of a sudden the s p 500 and
others are being increasingly driven
or i don't want to say overweighted but
driven by tech stocks that get harder
and harder to sort of defeat although
the pendulum swings both ways so
that's something that i thought about
for a period of time in conversation
with a number of friends of mine which
of my current views would change if my
incentives were different
this is very apropos of
the moment we live in right now yeah
thinking about this the other day
because
i get sent all sorts of stuff related to
science and vaccines and this that and
the other thing and i have friends
across the entire spectrum and they're
like what do you think of this what do
you think of this what do you think of
this and my general
response to a lot of it is
be very cautious about
people who
develop a brand for themselves that they
are compensated for whether it's
financially or reputationally maybe it's
just vanity and they get a lot of
youtube views
or having a certain position strong
position because they cannot or they're
probably unwilling to change that
position right like they've just
put themselves in a position where they
feel like they cannot change
their
stated position and that's a that's a
very dangerous place to be for a whole
lot of reasons but how would you answer
this for yourself
personally if i was paid per
page view on on the blog i would write
the blog differently i don't know how
but i know it would be because right now
it just never comes to mind it's just
not part of the equation i just want to
write what i think is good but if i was
if it was like oh i'm only going to get
paid
if this goes viral if it's shareable on
twitter i would i would write headlines
totally different the article's probably
much shorter much punchier than they are
now so i think that's a big part of it
if i was paid you know selling products
by commission if i was a financial
advisor selling by commission i would
probably be much more into active
investing and activist strategies than i
am right now
i think because i'm not a financial
advisor i'm not giving people advice i
can just kind of view it as an outsider
and be like well this is what makes
sense to me so that's what i'm going to
do whereas i know that if i was in the
trenches so to speak and had to make a
living doing this i know i would have
very different views about what
strategies you should pursue and i know
that the strategies that i would lean
towards would be higher fee higher
commission i think just think that's the
reality of it most people who work in
finance are good honest noble people not
all of them but most of them are but to
the extent that there is bad advice that
gets perpetuated i really just think it
comes down to the incentives that are in
the industry
i mean the perfect example of this is
that the only firm that's really been
able to make a good business out of
selling passive funds is vanguard and
they've done it by becoming a non-profit
that's the only way that you can do it
you can't make a good business out of
selling the lowest fee funds that are
out there you just can't do it
so i i know that if i had a different
compensation structure i would think
differently as an investor
last question from this list what are we
ignoring today that will seem shockingly
obvious in a year
it's probably something about covid and
it's either going to be that we're way
too scared or not nearly enough scared i
don't i don't know i don't know what
that is but i think that's that that's
what comes to mind when i when i think
about that that we'll look back a year
from now as we look back a year
one year ago today and a year before
that is like oh it was it was obvious
that this is where we're gonna like it's
always obvious in hindsight what's gonna
happen so i i have a feeling it'll be
something around covent but i won't
venture a guess which direction what
else anything else come to mind
i think it'll be obvious that the 2022
election is is going to be a disaster in
one way or another i won't even again i
won't try to guess which way that's
going to go or what the details are
going to be but i i have a feeling that
there will never be a clean uncontested
election for the rest of our lives i
think that's probably once you set the
precedent of chaos that it's hard to put
that genie back in the bottle yeah and i
was thinking about and i think i
actually saw this and i interrupted you
so we should probably mention you're
discussing books and then you mentioned
jason zweig and i i took us off the
reservation somewhere
actually do you want to finish that
thought and then i'll add something to
that because i think it was actually a
tweet it may have been a tweet that he
retweeted that i saw which leads me to a
thought about what might be obvious in a
year
that is perhaps not immediately obvious
but what uh were you going to reference
a book that jason wrote yeah jason's
book your money and your brain which
came out probably 2005 2006 and it was
one of the first behavioral finance
books out there behavioral finance is
pretty popular and and ubiquitous today
but back then not that long ago it
wasn't and his book was kind of a bold
look at like hey money is not
spreadsheets it's dopamine and cortisol
and that was yeah like i would say today
that's not a very profound statement but
that back then it was so i think he was
brave to write that book and it really
changed my view
of what matters in investing that was
one of the first like oh okay i i this
makes sense to me it's not about excel
it's about just how you think and how
you behave
yeah
i
am going to try to find
this
here it is
it is a tweet from jason so a few years
ago
a few years ago naval rovcon and i were
having a conversation on the podcast
and he talked about
the
the asymmetric costs of offense and
defense in a world where drones are
weaponized
meaning if you have a drone or
a bunch of tiny drones that are
weaponized and this is being developed
all over the world of course you have
sophisticated attacks where they can be
coordinated with software to say all
land on a given tank and explode at once
they can be used in more ad hoc
improvised ways
but i've been tracking this space
because a number of my friends are
involved
some of them design and
manufacture predator drones for instance
so a drone that would sort of kill or
capture other drones and they use
netting that is shot out like spider-man
to catch
drones and they're used by different
major league sports franchises because
that's a
non-trivial threat to say an arena would
be
drone attacks
and jason has a tweet this is from
december 7th 2021 saudi arabia is
running out of the ammunition to defend
against drone and missile attacks
from rebels in yemen i can't pronounce
the houthi it might be i'm sure i'm
pronouncing that incorrectly rebels in
yemen is appealing to the us and its
golf and european allies for a resupply
this is in the wall street journal
and
the
lead or at least the teaser sentence
that i see presented by wall street
journal
is saudi arabia's defense against the
rebels drones pits one million dollar
missiles against ten thousand dollar
flying lawn mowers in quotation marks i
remember that yeah that's that's a great
way to phrase like the problem that
you're dealing with and like who has the
edge here it's crazy yeah i mean the
future of warfare is here right not to
not to to beat poor william gibson's
quote to death but you know the future's
already here it's just not evenly
distributed but this is something that
i've been watching very closely because
the consequences are so
the potential consequences and the
implications are so
terrifying
so not uh not to end on that
but
i i only saw that tweet today
from jason and i it served as a reminder
to me that i think you know in a year
particularly with the
sort of technological development
cycles that we're seeing how compressed
they are and the innovations that we're
seeing from drum manufacturers i mean i
i i recently had my
uh some interactions with
the newer drones and drones with fleur
technology and infrared tracking
capabilities
it is
incredibly
impressive i mean compared to drones
from even 18 months ago i mean they are
like worlds apart it is shockingly
impressive so here's what's scary to me
about that too is that
when the nuclear bomb came about there
was obviously fear that like this is
this is the future of war and
knock on one figure's cross it has not
since 1945 because the consequences of a
nuclear war are so catastrophic that
everyone who has them up until this
point i said it's not not worth using
them because the consequences are so
severe i almost think drone war is the
opposite where it's like there's no skin
in the game you're not sacrificing any
soldiers lives you're sacrificing
civilian lives of course on the other
side but
there's so little skin in the game and
it's so easy to just flip these things
up in the air and go for it that it
makes
starting a war progressing a war so much
easier than it's ever been it's the
opposite of what happened with nuclear
war over the last 80 years yeah if
people want to make an attempt at
looking around some corners also from a
technical perspective with respect to
a.i and cyber warfare
i highly recommend listening to my
recent podcast with with eric schmidt it
is
mind-boggling
what else i think that within a year
we will have things like gpt3
at a point where we can generate
probably
i would say within a year might be
aggressive but you know within 18 months
with figures who have enough audio
online that you can really deep fake
effectively you'll have sort of
synthetic interviews
with people alive and dead that are
convincing enough that they can't be
distinguished from live interview i
could see that being graspable in the
next 12 to 18 months and that just
torpedoes trust even more than it's ever
been like you hear a quote from tim
ferriss and you're like i don't even who
like that's probably not even tim so i
don't even take it seriously anymore
there's no trust anywhere oh election
cycle 2022 it's gonna be uh
exciting i got my son in oculus for
christmas and there's a thing where you
can do a tour of the white house with
barack and michelle it was it was filmed
back then
and just as sitting at a table in vr
having a conversation with barack obama
it was the it was so shockingly
realistic and you know where that's
going that that the the vr headsets that
we have 10 years from now are going to
make this look like a complete joke if
you could if you mix that
with
the ability to deep fix like it's we're
heading into a world that's going to be
so wild
a couple of final questions for you i
would also just recommend
it's a fun film as well people could
read the book certainly but ready player
one people should take a look at that
it's coming a lot sooner than people
think
a lot sooner than people will expect
and
websites you know there was a there's a
site that came up in your conversation
with shane abnormal returns i've never
heard of this site yep as i understand
it it is basically a news aggregator
human curated
i don't know who runs the site i've
never been to it but uh
what is abnormal returns and there are
there any other websites that you think
are might be interesting for folks to
explore as resources yeah so abnormal
returns is run by a guy named taras
viscantes and he is a financial
professional himself and he runs what i
think is the best financial news
aggregator he he is just an absolute
machine he reads every financial article
that's been published
in the previous day and he aggregates
the top 20 of them or so every single
day he's been doing it since 2006 i
think and he's the best that's out there
that's like that's uh that's a site that
i visit every single day because i know
that
whatever the best financial article that
was written the previous day he's going
to have it right there i don't need to
spend hours sifting it's just he's got
it right there and i can i can go to his
site it's like like a one-stop shop
tough life he's signed up for keeping
that up for years and decades but i
appreciate it he's done it appreciate
the effort he's never slowed down either
i don't think he's ever missed a day
that i've seen and he's been doing it
for i don't know 15 20 years it's
incredible wow keep up the good fight
that is incredible uh any other any
other websites that stand out for you
that people might not be familiar with
there's a site called
blast.comblas.com it's run by this guy
named blas morose who's a really cool
guy
and
he reads more than anyone i've ever seen
i think he he must read two books per
week something like that and then he
makes a fairly detailed summary of every
book that he's ever read and they're not
quick summaries some of them are like
five page pdfs but you can just go in
there and he summarized
hundreds and hundreds of books into a
five-page pdf with the key points the
big takeaways and he does a better job
at it of any other book summary service
that i've seen and it's all free it's
just his private blog that's out there i
can get lost in his website for hours
just finding these little nuggets in
these obscure books that i've never
heard of and he has all the highlights
right there that is a great
recommendation we'll link to that in the
show notes everybody
what stories
or points do you wish people paid more
attention to in the psychology of money
if anything or what would people gloss
over or you're like god damn it you
missed the point
sure not everybody but there's one point
like one thing that doesn't irk me but i
just think it's interesting is when i
talked about that we don't have a
mortgage and i know that was a dumb
decision but here's why we did it
because it makes us feel good a lot of
people i get emails that are like yeah
but look at the spreadsheet that i made
the numbers don't add up and i'm like i
know i'm trying to explain like the idea
i need to be rational instead of just
reasonable and using money to give me a
better life i still like that that still
didn't land with some people maybe
that's my fault as a writer i'm not
explaining it well that's that's one
point to me i think the most important
part of the book
that i think a lot of people got but is
i feel like it was it's the single most
important thing it's just this idea that
everyone is different they have
different goals different personalities
different risk tolerances and therefore
we should not expect any of us to come
to the same conclusion about what's the
right thing to do with our money and i
think that can be hard for people
because you still have these financial
debates of like this person's investing
their money this way that's wrong they
should be doing it a different way it's
like well we're all so different that
like what works for me might be terrible
for you and vice versa even if we're
just as smart as one another same
education same information we're always
going to come to different conclusions
we just need to accept that yeah and but
before you start sprinting headlong
towards
winning the game making damn sure that
you've defined very clearly what your
game is and what your game is not is
very very very very helpful
morgan people can find you on twitter at
morgan household
your website is
i believe morganhousel.com which we'll
link to
is that right
yeah i would say the website to go it's
good morganhouse.com it's just like uh
it just has my email address i would say
the website is just the collaborative
funds that's where everything i write is
all right so we'll link to the
collaborative fund as well is there
anything else you would like to say any
closing comments requests of the
audience things to point them to
complaints uh
anything at all that you'd like to
to share before we wrap up
tim i've i've admired you for a very
long time and it's an honor to get to do
this so thank you for having me oh well
i really appreciate admire your work as
well
this book
is on my
to repeat read list that's why i've gone
through the notes multiple times which i
did before we ever
ended up scheduling this conversation
and i've recommended it to a lot of
friends
and i don't do that lightly right there
is a reputational risk books take some
time to read so
i i generally will will withhold my
recommendations
unless i am absolutely sure but
the reframing and the perspectives and
the hypotheticals and the thought
exercises and this is true of your
articles as well i've seen this
i find to be very
powerful because
you're not
just sharing opinions you're not just
giving a prescription based on your own
experience but you're you're
doing your best to help someone
look at their own situation or at a
generalized situation differently and i
think that that provides a sort of
universal
cognitive and psychological toolkit that
people can then apply to their own
individual circumstances so i applaud
that and i i
have to imagine that it was not easy to
get the book to the place where
it ended up in final form i know that
that was probably very challenging
and
i really really enjoyed it and i expect
to continue to enjoy it so thanks for
taking the time today
well thank you and i i enjoy your work
just as much i've learned just as much
so let's end with that mutual high five
mutual high five and everybody listening
we'll put links to everything discussed
in the show notes at tim.blog
podcast you can just search morgan and
it'll pop right up and until next time
thank you for tuning in
you